tout le monde est minutieuse ennemis
dont soir bienvenue sur le plateau de
tout le monde en parle
vous connaissez le principe ciment de ce
conte depuis le temps tout le monde en
parle
alors tout le monde en parle vous
connaissez les qui voici mines d'albi
l'ensemble 1
la gymnastique on réussit très bien
senti mais en faire franchement on voit
tout de suite et résultat beaucoup
j'accueille maintenant celui que votre
courrier me réclament toutes les
semaines malheureusement certaines
semaines ne peut pas venir parce qu'ils
la piscine voici laurent baffie
sané première invitée ce soir est un
humoriste qui s'est imposé avec brio
dans le métier de comédiens et de
réalisateurs de films aussi alain chabat
soir alors oui mais à l'occasion d'une
cassette qui s'appelle les briques old
girls voit la bricole d'esprit call girl
voilà donc on en parlera tout à l'heure
on peut lui dire déjà un mot maintenant
c'est une cassette de bricolage
présentées par d'autres filles sublimes
créatures
c'est une cassette pratique devrait
bricolage je vous ai préparé un petit
sampler pour vous alors en hommage à
didier
[Musique]
c'est quoi déjà c'est we can work it out
des beatles a chanté par des chiens
ouais alors à par alain chabat et
laurent baffie chaque année ce soir dans
l'émission fabrice luchini gimmicks
salaces
jacky
louis amazon est la championne du monde
de sprint flessel bon alors nous sommes
tous des missions se regarder ce qui
s'est passé mieux la semaine précédente
ça s'appelle tout le monde a parlé
magnéto est ce que c'est vrai que vous
êtes resté très copain avec elie alors
il faut que je m'en attendais il faut
que je vois là je me mets dans la peau
d'un monteur s'est pas fait ses achats
oui alors pour répondre et pour mentir
je dirais je ne pardonne pas et lits
d'accueil salle voilà si je devais dire
la vérité je ne dit pas la vérité c'est
l'interview manceau faisait tout [ __ ]
en l'air
je suis un fan de la gaffe oui ou non
ils n'arrivent pas à manger dit non mais
la gaffe je les rencontre et on a
discuté
il aa discussions derrière on arrive à
parler bon bah c'est sûr qu'elle mais
bon il va pas écrire de la poésie va pas
de faire un alexandrin tai-chi pas à
l'alexandra qu est-ce que c'est vrai que
vous avez un sexe énorme
je refuse d'appuyer encore sur un vieux
poncifs qui une fois de plus alors je la
pose à tout le monde la question oui ça
pourrait non mais attention aux tirs et
je lui ai posé albert mais je
connaissais la réponse banker
comme votre père vous engage si vous
voyez pas que c'est le gros mot des
trucs bien jusque là où jusque là elle
s'est bien comportée découdra de rein
devra donc l'amour
hier a alors assuré que j'espère que
monsieur célarié rassurer donc papa oui
papa je sais ce que je dis [ __ ]
non mais attention vous êtes mieux quand
vous faites pas attention à ce que vous
dites est adjoint au maire ou et où il
est autre que monsieur tiberi il est
branché préparé un petit jingle pour
tibéri écouter
[Musique]
fier
bien qu on se
le fermer
oui oui on a tant fait on tape en train
d or aux gens j'ai entendu que je chirac
inviter quelqu'un dans un château qui
lui appartient pas aux touristes les
payer château ne sais pas moi mais bon
je veux tel choc aux personnes habitant
sa femme sa femme wahiba épouser une
femme qu'un château royal est une femme
allaitante
non non et non alors question c'est
l'âge de 26 ans va être page 26 ou non
mais attendez il m'a demandé un truc
intéressant
moi il m'a demandé si je pensais écrire
un autre livre
oui je sais tout juste position 1 je
vous pose
l'investissement 8e libre je n'ai jamais
dit que c'était le premier but est un
dictateur à bas ce serait une claire
forcément vous étiez un supplice la
conversation je vous étiez une infirmité
cas l'infirmité seriez-vous en bas
je suis une infirme voilà c'était tout
le monde en a parlé
le best-of de la semaine dernière
alors la sabam bricole gurls vous êtes
en bricolage
voilà je vous êtes nuls en bricolage
ouais et vous avez décidé de faire
cadeau à un cadeau pas vraiment cadeau
de combien je ne sais pas bricoler et
j'aime les belles filles c'est un
concept que j'ai réunis en une seule
cassette
vous avez fait casting commente
j'imagine chez pas en script
soutien-gorge petite culotte
si on n'a pas des forcément des idées
qui passent pas les bouger la perceuse
un peu le texte qui peut que je vais sur
mes cinquante donc ça commence à être
témoin des numéros absurde de charme
incroyable sûr que normand fait non mais
c'est vrai que c'était c'est difficile
de dire voilà vous allez donc décollé du
papier peint ça dégage de la vapeur il
fait très chaud vous déshabiller pour
être plus à l'aise à les hits quand même
mettre les filles à l'aise de lentilles
bah oui oui mais mais je leur ai dit que
c'était extrêmement extrêmement c'était
plus que et qu'aucun puisque puisque
même sexy quand même fait le crêpier la
fin nsn a peu à peu alors dans cette
cassette et jamel qui vous donne un coup
de main ouais ouais mais là il m'a
demandé si c'était une connerie
les bricoleurs ou si c'était vrai donc
j'ai dit que c'était un peu c'est vrai
que c'est un peu les deux c'est une
connerie mais que c'était c'était vrai
donc il m'a demandé ce que je peux faire
une bêtise dedans les pelles etc suzanne
donc je dis bien sûr on va regarder
djamel magnéto serge s'il te plaît
bonjour elle s'appelle samantha dizaines
de jeunes se basent les hommes là elle
va vous donner des conseils en bricolage
corps est comme moi je suis un érudit en
bilingue je vais tous vous traduire sans
exception d'accord vous pouvez me faire
confiance
un ballet de guangzhou mène pour la
traduction
oui oui ça quand vous voulez alors pour
aller à bordeaux c'est super sympa faut
pas faire comme les autres qui vous
voyez qui passe par dampierre qui passe
par le triangle de rocquencourt ce sans
savoir où aller car il ya des
fluctuations dit si je me trompe
la a6 la a6 bus lahore
prenez la santé cité en deux heures vous
êtes sur bordeaux n'est ce pas il est
bien sûr ça dépend de vous parler de
façon continue d'avaler ça je me suis
dit ça y est ça un message et jamel
qu'est ce que dit exactement avait
changé ses habits d'accord qu'elle avait
un peu chaud pour cent d'accord toutes
ses amies qu'elle connaït go oui oui
mais là bas ce canal
vidéo disons le c'est un cadeau de noël
extraordinaire
moi je trouve à 99 francs franchement
c'est que 99 francs cassettes et dvd
ah ouais ça alors offrir ça n'aurait non
et est-ce qu'après vous allez faire
d'autre qu'à 7 vendredi relais les
kitchen dell qui sont d'aider des
magnifiques chippendales qui vont donner
des recettes de cuisine
je viens faire le casting est
cordialement invitée linda parce que le
casting sera effectivement fait part des
copines pour avoir un peu leurs canons
masculin quoi voilà en fait au départ on
devait sortir les deux en même temps
puis on est passé de sous à huy canal +
vidéo n'a pas assez de ça non mais là
personne n'en voulait moi j'ai fait tout
seul et puis après je les proposer à
canal que dit oui mais ah oui c'est une
idée vraiment à vous au départ c'est
super pour perdre de l'argent un petit
peu d'ambition artistique vous êtes une
ambition artistique une vrai qu'à cette
pratique bien alors votre premier film
c'était là on l'a dit tout à l'heure la
cité de la peur après le gazon maudit
qui a été quand même le film qui vous a
fait connaître en tant qu' en tant
qu'acteur c'est vrai que celui de
l'eczéma sous les bras tellement vous
aviez le trac mais c'est exact c'est
très glamour ça parce que si j'avais une
bourse non non ouais ouais bah oui je
vous retrouver dans l'intimité avec
alain chabat avait demandé lui de lever
les braves sylla de l'eczéma sous les
bras ces quelques heures il ya un
tournage en prévision merci thierry à
sebala c'était à l'achat
mais le pire était à venir
bon alors le cap et ya eu un cousin
métiers extraordinaires comme un
vraiment vous a découvert comme acteur
non parce qu'au début on vous prenez un
peu pour en brûler un futur la vérité je
suis un branleur mais non c'est une
imposture dont super bon comédien
oui vous pensez toujours que ça va
s'arrêter que les gens vont vous dire
vont s'apercevoir un jour que c'est nous
mais surtout beaucoup de grands acteurs
qui pensent ça c'est pour ça que je dis
ça il pense toujours qu'un jour là là le
carrosse va redevenir une citrouille
vous pensez ça bien sûr non mais oui c c
on pense que c'est très grave au point
ça va être plus grave
mais dans le camp le cousin j'étais très
bien merci était bien dirigée par
monsieur corneau sur toi alors lui
disiez que vous avez réalisés dont là je
vous remettre votre petit coin alors la
personne je crois que vous allez faire
votre premier film c'est diane kurys et
après vous avez des ennuis avec elle au
sujet de didier aux gens mais qu'on en
parle parce qu'on a vu des tout temps
des petits bonds dans les journaux où
elle vous accuser de plagiat en disant
c'est une idée didier que j'ai raconté
un soir dans un dîner alain chabat et
puis je marquais les 10 ha ouais non je
peux dire ou alors parce que comme ça ce
sera clair ouais non c'est un je crois
qu'ils aient développé aux états unis un
sujet sur un petit garçon qui
transformait son frère en chien un truc
comme ça et après moi je vais raconter
mon truc gémit tiens je prépare ça et
c'est tout ça ensuite me revient cette
histoire qu'elle avait déjà développé en
fait avant avant que je lui parle de ça
mais je ne le savais pas et on me dit
tiens et développe un et développe un
film avec un mec qui transforme en chien
ou j'sais pas quoi donc forcément je me
prends les nerfs parce que j'avais
raconté le truc donc je l'appelle et les
insultes enfin je l'insultais les idées
n'appartiennent pas ce qu'ils ont
entendu les appartiennent aux
gouvernants de la gamme dit mais non
mais non mais non finalement 1 est
effectivement enfin
il avait raison vu qu'elle n'avait
vraiment développé avec voilà quelqu'un
moi je le savais pas donc après comme on
s'est embrouillé tous les deux le truc a
donné ce à quoi le truc a donné il a
plagié mon film qu'elle n'a jamais eue
avec un avec un barman déjà pour diabolo
menthe
elle est coutumière du fait en fait on
n'a jamais eu de procès on sait juste
expliquer tous les deux il ya ni procès
ni plagiat mais est ce que c'est pour ça
qu'il ya pas eu un didier parce qu'à un
moment où vous deviez faire la version
américaine de didier est ce que c'est
pour ça qu'il ya eu la version
américaine de non non non non la version
américaine d'audi a toujours acheté par
miramax qu'une société de production
invoquée avec les frères weinstein et on
a travaillé dessus presque un an et demi
mais au bout d'un moment j'étais obligé
de leur dire que j'avais j'avais une vie
quoi et que je pouvais pas attendre
assis sur une caisse que le truc se
fasse pas donc je suis rentré à ma
maison
vous étiez partis vivre là bas je
faisais des allers retours j'ai fait des
allers-retours est beaucoup entre
paris et new york ce qui est agréable
c'est est payé par la production était
ravie je vais manger des hot dogs j'ai
grossi et tout ça est invaincu est
devenue une véritable usine à merde là
bas c'est monstrueux quand on bouffait
ce confit mais sinon c'était donc voilà
donc ils semblent ils le font avec un
autre metteur en scène qui s'appelle
stephen schwartz qui avait fait chou
thing fish qui mettait en scène anglais
très bien donc maintenant bon courage à
lui parce qu'il sait pas des rapides
quoi ouais ouais alors ça quand même un
mal pour un bien parce que ça vous
permet de faire la suite d'astérix
c'est fait ça non non c'est j'ai
commencé à écrire donc il fait ça voilà
ouais ça risque d'être moins
franchouillard que j'ai dit ça risque
d'être plus marrant non
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas si j'ai
envie de faire ma version à moins non
non je vais pas d'instructions j'ai je
fais ces ruminants l'aurait créé avec
talent casting oui c'est pourquoi non
pour savoir si clavier va le reprendre
le rôle moi je trouve qu'il n'est pas
crédible dans le rôle mais non savoir si
tu changes ça non je ne change pas
clavier je ne change pas de part dieu
comme c'est astérix et cléopâtre il ya
ces adjani ou bouquets alors c'est très
gênant parce que sais je sais pas qui
s'est vu que effectivement ses sorties
je suis effectivement côté dit un peu
rapidement
donc j'ai jamais rencontré adjani je
suis j'aime beaucoup adjani comme
comédienne mais non j'en suis à
l'écriture et je ne sais même pas qui va
faire faire payer ce bonus n'est pas une
bonne idée
il ya déjà belle c'est sûr ça qui fait
l'architecte de kyo pas non non il n'y a
rien de veria n'ya rien de sûr pour nous
enfumer les pétards en écrivant le
script
c'est le meilleur moment c'est le
meilleur moment exactement
ouais quand on monte les marches ouais
un alcool et sacha guitry fait de
meilleur moment dans l'amour c'est
exactement ce pas réellement l'écriture
ouais je cultive avec grâce à ces jeunes
doivent un joli nez linda aussi il est
gentil
c'est pour ces la truffe du chien
alors on va faire un tabac une interview
à l'envers c'est ce que c'est une
interview à l'envers oui c'est une
interview vous donner les réponses et
vian jacques alain chabat h une émission
[Musique]
une
voilà non mais c'est surtout parce que
c'est très bien j'ai bien alors je vous
donne les réponses comme vous l'avez
différemment et puis vous me donnez les
questions alors la réponse mettant c'est
fabrice luchini qui est le meilleur
acteur français parce que vient en même
temps philippe sollers
[ __ ] alors je n'ai jamais lu un livre
de comment il s'appelle déjà
je suis totalement inculte mais bien
suis pas qu'elle célèbre écrivain
français a une coupe de merde aussi
philippe ça marche bien donc je donne la
réponse
laurent baffie moi je dirais que c'est
un type formidable
déjà je parle a decir côté humain de la
personne way puis après tu peut broder
là-dessus d'accord qui à ce mélange de
2,2 grâce d'humour de talent de
sex-appeal
j'sais pas linda hardy qui mériterait
d'avoir des plus grosses le lot vous
mettez votre main ici là parce que je
sais ce que vous non par la suite un
travail de la preuve il a fallu que je
suis mariée j'ai des enfants linda linda
retenus qui a la main droite qui part un
peu en couille alors bravo tu sais tu
continues tu sais très bien guy bedos
qui ne manque pas de toupet bien qu'on
nous applaudit on rallume la lumière de
rester avec nous très bien bien
j'accueille maintenant fabrice luchini
[Applaudissements]
vous mettez là ouais
fabrice luchini bonsoir je vous ai
préparé un petit jingle pour vous bien
là il établit en art 10 ans est très
sympa ça j'apprécie beaucoup vous un peu
du noir comme alors fabrice luchini vous
avez déclaré
le pire c'est évidemment la télévision
elle peut rendre antipathique alors
qu'on a tout simplement le trac mais
quand on a tourné un film il faut bien
les défendre
alors l'occurrence et un en l'occurence
est un spectacle vous avez le trac vous
à la télé mais oui bien sûr je veux dire
invoqué ray ouais j'ai fait une ou deux
émissions et fabrice et j'ai un peu une
ou deux émissions je sais un peu comment
il fonctionne c'est qu'il arrive
toujours tout timide et ré où il dit un
mot puis un deuxième et à la fin il
rachète la production qui parle et il va
chanter adamo dans cinq minutes
c'est une collaboration délicate pour
vous parce que ce qui aurait pu se
passer quand été
chat et déjà et est déjà menacé avocats
auraient été pas mal parce que ça fait
une émission de t c'est un tu vas dire
adamo quand même là bas elle a
maintenant que c'est vendu comme ça je
suis ma vessie si moi j'ai sur moi je
demande de l'accent pieds noirs
moi je suis d'abord très très heureux
d'abord avant tout d'être avec d'être
près de vous qui avez fait un film
immense
je le redis didier grand film n'essayez
pas de m'embrouiller alors allez-y donc
fabrice luchini vous reprenez à partir
du 4 décembre spectacle au théâtre de la
madeleine
oui oui c'est un véritable succès
populaire combien de gens sont venus
déjà le voit ça fait 450 ou 500
présentations ça doit faire deux cent
mille personnes deux cent mille
personnes
et là c'est déjà il paraît enfin sceller
les patrons du théâtre de la madeleine
qui disent ça c'est que les gens quand
ils ont su que ça allait commencer ils
ont déjà téléphoner pour réserver avant
même qu'ils aient de la promotion ou qui
est d affligeant paris c'est vrai voyez
un peu un petit peu un petit peu vrai
c'est pas cher à ses cent premiers plats
sont à 100 francs aux mille îles et cher
sont à 2 102 110 à 210 on vous entend
être sang froid
on vous voit les moyennement cher ils
sont 150
dans vous dites des textes d'hugo ou de
baudelaire de nietzsche de la fontaine
de céline vous pouvez nous en dire un
petit bout céline dion quoique non pas
tout de suite
ouais non mais je pense que ça va se
détendre il n'ya pas d'étendre notre ami
non mes shows campus en général c'est
quelqu'un qui cite des citations à un
moment précis dans un contexte
particulier que parfois on lui a
reproché ce soit de la pédanterie qu'en
fait je pense que c'est plus une forme
d'humilité et que quand les autres quand
on n'est pas content on peut pas trouver
les mots pour les dire et quand d'autres
personnes l'ont très bien dit je trouve
que c'est l'ambiance se détend et elle
s'élève surtout a donc c'est derrière
que quand même grâce à ça vous
mademoiselle comme toujours souvent à
part les artistes les véritables par les
artistes véritable qui ont une grosse
non pas top mais une énorme féminité dès
qu'on est face aux halles et héros qui
veut tout de suite faire le brillant sap
sap l'ombre quand les femmes passent à
élèves ou alors quand on a un metteur en
scène de talent tout d'un coup
l'ambiance est bonne on a un compliment
quand on rend ton anti cia baffie
qu'immédiatement entravent le mouvement
s'est dit hier je refuse devenu un
par rapport aux hommes vous dites
souvent que ce que vous dites ce que
vous détestez chez les hommes c'est leur
manque de civilité
vous avez dit un jour la chose la pire
c'est la lourdeur la bêtise la vulgarité
des hommes
en volant au volant par exemple ils sont
vulgaires les mecs leur bagnole seller
phallus leur petit zizi faut que ça
groove ça vrombit ya pas de jean gol
saint-hyacinthe où tu vas tu y ailles
non au contre la déjantée que d'autres
mais moi j'étais je vais être franc je
suis quelqu'un qui qui débute à la
télévision et je vous connaissais pas
beaucoup et j'ai été fasciné par des
choses que vous dites comme vous êtes un
autodidacte je trouve que c'est
justement la façon de vous parler des
hommes et dont vous parlez des femmes a
beaucoup mal de recoller allait bien non
je vous avais une ouverture la c1 là je
crois que fait quand on vous voit
sérieusement revoir on cherche une
explication de ce qu'est une sorte de
génie c'est vrai que c'est pas de la
flagornerie que vous dire ça à toute
façon et vous dites je ne suis pas
intelligente j'ai des intuitions des
parfois des fulgurances comme ça et je
peux sentir à merveille le mouvement
d'une phrase une espèce de dons et c'est
vrai que vous savez non sérieusement
vous savez restituer le le poids des
mots l'essentiel vous dit l'essentiel
dans le métier c'est de restituer vous
savez restituer le poids des mots ça y
est c'est ma passion quoi enfin voila il
fait des films il fait des blagues
elle fait de l'intelligence et du charme
vous êtes efficace c'est très
intelligent et moi mon boulot c'est de
restituer le génie d immense écrivain et
d-sub 20h alors séduit uniquement de la
de l'obsession et de la névrose avoir
cinq objectifs y en a ils veulent se
faire des meufs qui en a ils veulent
avoir des grosses bagnoles y en a qui
veulent du pognon moi je suis toujours
été et est fasciné par ce que
représentait une phrase n'importe
laquelle une grande phrase quand un
écrivain a une dimension immense tu te
dis comment un acteur ne va pas entraver
la beauté l'innocence de cette phrase
comment il va faire comment il va faire
pour tout détruire comment il va aplatir
là il ya un moyen soit il n'a aps la
tipa il devient un vrai comédien ou soit
il essaye d'être à la hauteur ou la
phrase a été écrite à ce qui est encore
plus étonnant chez vous quand on voit ce
spectacle c'est que vous avez
parfaitement autodidacte si vous avez
et à l'école ce que certif et vous avez
arrêté très tôt donc à l'âge de 13 ans
et demi après vous êtes tous rattrapés à
quelle époque vous avez tous rattrapés
ah bah je suis en train alors contraint
longtemps que j'ai toujours attraper
comme un nom c'est un travail quotidien
vous en êtes interminable
là je suis vous savez malheureusement je
suis très obsessionnel c'est à dire je
je travaille les mêmes textes toujours
les mêmes comme des gammes inlassable
vous avez dit quand j'ai commencé je
sais même pas ce que c'était une amibe
enfin parce que ça c'est le programme
secondaire depuis la 6e à la fois aller
en 16e pour savoir ce qu'est ce que
c'est une amie mon nom du tout vous
n'êtes pas en sixième mais non j'ai vu
si je n'ai pas beaucoup changé depuis
que je suis avec vous mais faire juste
qui n'agit qu'il ait appris grâce à une
une fiancée merveilleuse qui était l'ami
d'une guitariste oui vous avez appris
aussi grâce à quelqu'un que vous
connaissez sa vie parker ya un truc
encore il va se passer quelque chose me
gâcher toujours
soit parce que les filles parce que
c'est une fille vacances avec moi c'est
une amie bailleur n'a ici qu'à un animal
unicellulaires qui a des poils scellier
pour se déplacer il comprenait pourquoi
il est là maintenant mais je voulais
aller au bout de l'histoire
ce qui est encore plus étonnant fabrice
et que vous n'avez jamais eu la vocation
vous dites ne sais même pas ce que
c'était la vocation quand j'étais petit
la vocation c'est un truc qui n'a pas
grand quine et ça veut rien dire c'est
très quel est votre interrogation réel
mon interrogation réel c'est savoir quoi
comment quelqu'un qui a commencé dans le
temps on se balade dans ruera mais dans
le quartier de la goutte d'or en
singeant le pape et en faisant la quête
en baisse faisant semblant de bénir les
gens comment ce petit garçon là qui
s'est arrêté d'aller à l'école à l'âge
de 13 ans 13 ans et demi que sa mère a
mis dans un salon de coiffure qui s'est
retrouvée un jour à angoulême en se
déhanchant dans une boîte de nuit et qui
étaient remarqués par philippe labro
comment ce type qui n'était dingue que
de que deux fringants fête et de musique
type
voilà mon interrogation est là qui
n'avaient pas la vocation
comment il est devenu fabrice luchini
aujourd'hui il ya des milliers de gens
qui vont le voir sur scène racontée du
baudelaire du rictus d'hugo du nietzsche
et du céline vallat genou il ya quelque
chose pour moi qui est de l'ordre du
miracle
voilà un jeu j'essaye de peu pour moi
aussi j'aurais pas prévu du tout les
choses comme ça au delà de réciter ses
textes et une grâce qui vous est tombé
dessus que quelqu'un comme marraine
concept de moi je suis pas responsable
de la grâce et qui est des écrivains
géniaux après les interprètes ils font
leur boulot
la grâce c'est qu'il ya des génies c'est
ça la grâce la grâce et qui a des mecs
qui s'appelle baudelaire la fontaine et
qui ont capté avec une certitude une
intuition in ciselure des mots tellement
parfaite des sentiments du coeur humain
et que nous pouvons nous
connaître pourquoi la plus belle phrase
qui a été dit sur ce spectacle c'est
michel bouquet et cochet qui l'ont dit
michel bouquet est venu écouter ce
spectacle sur la fontaine et sur céline
il m'a dit en partant une phrase
incroyable qui est une source
d'inspiration il m'a dit je comprends je
comprends l'intérêt c'est parce que le
public sort de ce spectacle renseigné
sur lui même et bien ses auteurs là où
une vertu il renseigne les êtres humains
sur eux mêmes mais vous qui nous
intéresse nous c'est de voir comment
vous avez fait votre parcours cochet
travail
le petit bâton dans la dans la bouche a
pas que ça parce que quand grosseur de
travail des heures de colle bien avec ça
parce que quand vous êtes dans votre
boutique dans la boutique de vos parents
tout enfant vous observez vous vous
écoutez le commerce est une bonne école
donc il n'y a pas que ça il n'y a pas eu
cochet effectivement mais avant cochet
du décès de cette façon de transformer
ses faiblesses en forces que vous avez
eu depuis depuis toujours ça ça existe
c'est l'héritage de ta mère et ton père
sam c'est que tu leur bar se lancer sur
un truc très pointue de coin de quoi on
peut se vanter certainement pas de nos
malheureux dont sur l'a23 dont chabat il
fait des films il a fait didier cas
remarquable il va pas arriver avec la
clope en disant je suis le roi de la
piste pour écraser vous le dit voilà il
ya un grand producteur il ya eu du
talent j'ai mis mon énergie j'étais
heureux il peut pas ramener à son ego
l'efficacité de son film moi je vais
quand même pas ramené à mon ego
l'efficacité de ce spectacle ce
spectacle c'est que le public n'aime les
auteurs sont géniaux et moi je suis
comme michel bouquet plus j'avance sur
moi même plus je comprends les
personnages qu'on me donne à jouer - j'y
comprend quelque chose sur moi je crois
que le vrai talent de ce spectacle c'est
l'amour que tu as des mots et la façon
de le vendre et d'expliquer et de
vulgariser je sais pas si le mot va te
plaire de vulgariser des grands auteurs
mais pas de sens de les rendre vulgaire
c'est un revendeur de les rendre
accessibles à des profanes et tu vas
donner envie de lire à certaines
personnes d'accord mais c'est que
c'était pas un projet personnel tu vois
pas le matin que je me suis levé un
matin en me prenant pour un jean vilar
bis en me disant fabrice
tu es né pour communiquer la grande
culture française nous ta destinée 5 tu
seras celui par lequel non pas le
scandale arrive
mais par lequel la littérature ce beau
bourne la littérature ou à la
littérature c'est pas de la littérature
du marais où naviguent avec moi ça
m'amuse d'être là parce que moi je
prends même je vous avez tout à fait
raison et vous êtes pertinents je dis tu
parce que j'aime en vue que j'ai préféré
dire tu c'est évident que l'ego modeste
est encore pire que l'ego machin mais
dans l'époque dans laquelle on est à
part des gens qui savent la traduire et
la lan et c'est que l'aïe
là je vais faire la fameux le fameux
cliché sur moi il ya une chose sur
l'humilité qui est écrit par nietzsche
qui est magnifique
parce que c'est vrai que ça se vend vhc
très van damme et l'humilité du comprend
un mec car les vrais qui dirait je suis
assez énorme spirituellement
actuellement je suis une bombe atomique
intellectuellement à par spinoza il ya
peu de mecs qui font le point et au
niveau du talent je pense que woody
allen
très sincèrement chaplin chaplin ou 10 à
l'animal mother sont un peu d'air à côté
de moi moi je suis non je ne en plus ça
pourrait être passionnante parler de
qu'est-ce que ça la modestie tous à la
modestie l'auteur
je suis content que mes malheureuse
phrase est une toute petite efficacité
sur votre corps car ce corps et mon
esprit également mais j'aimerais que ce
soit les deux vous le savez avantages
qu'ils nient
j'essaie de me rattraper donc je ne
saurai jamais en fait on ne sait pas
quand j'étais dans une école de
comptabilité j'étais dans une école de
comptabilité pendant un an l'on ne
parlait du bilan actif passif il fait ça
aussi bien rue ferdinand flocons dans le
xviiie arrondissement à 14 ans mamie
avenue montaigne dans un salon de
coiffure où on m'a parlé de permanente
de bigoudis de brushing puisque je
commence toujours en rétracter après
jeudi l'ate quand même mal à finir et
qu'elle d'amour tab énorme armée
traquait au début de l'année quand je me
suis retrouvé dans les permanentes et
après j'ai passé les épingles et après
les brosses et puis on m'a dit tu vas
accéder à la mèche on m'a dit oui tu vas
prendre une brosse ronde avec ton
séchoir s'énerve et lycéens les plus
grands moments de ma vie j'ai pris la
mèche et j'ai commencé à chauffer la
femme était hyper heureuse comme ça
disait je sens qu'ils sont lourds puis
elle les mettait ses cheveux et moi je
mettais une glace toujours et tu disais
vous êtes contente de ça et je mettais
tous ses cheveux en avant ce qui fait
qu'elle était hyper heureuse qui cède 0
mais quand vous me fait un brushing sont
lourds montrez-moi la glace derrière là
je remettais tout et elle faisait en
mille son lourd là aussi donc elle était
hyper heureuse j'ai appris le mentir
vrai sublime de jouvet le mentir vrai
alors quand je comprenais pas très bien
de quoi il était question d'un permanent
je vais arriver à votre réponse je
connais pas bien la permanence je
connais pas bien la comptabilité
je ne comprenais pas bien la colle la
couleur quant à nous est plein de soleil
fabrice du soleil avait du soleil
partout neige et que c'était la mode de
raquel welch a fêté peut réaliser
faites moi comme une tigresse blanche
problème approche ma brosse comme sa
pige tirait parce que vous savez dans la
coiffure on doit appuyer sur les racines
pour que ça gonfle donc je dirais pour
que ce soit bon fleyhane partech des
espèces de tête effrayante
ça m'a beaucoup passionné sauf que je ne
comprenais pas de tout ce dont il était
question après j'ai été dans plein
d'autres endroits et un jour à 23 ans
après avoir fait un film bizarre avec
eric rohmer un grand agent très connus
d'art médias m'a dit c'est un métier
vous avez un certain don bon c'est un
métier je suis rentré chez cochet et là
il s'est passé un truc comme ça que
thérèse d'avila et comme métriques à
cocher a mis en scène un musée il y
avait un acteur qui travaillait et
cochet a dit à l'acteur chaque phrase ce
que devait ce que l'acteur devait
nourrir pour que la phrase prenne sa
dimension et pour la première fois de ma
vie
pour la première fois y aller j'ai
compris de quoi on parlait c'est comme
si j'avais été autistes
c'est pas que je vous le fais j'ai pas
je vais pas imiter je ne comprenais pas
et le jour où j'ai entendu au dedans
routier devrait être vos battements le
pays est brûlant la moisson lescop été
braqué au coin de tout puissant et que
je voyais cochet qui est gênant mais pas
ton doigt comme ça alors on dirait les
frères ennemis ne met pas qu'on doit
faire qu'à dire simplement anciens
vainqueurs du monde espagnol que nous
sommes quelle armée avant nous et ils
illustraient le mystère du texte j'ai vu
la plus belle des choses comme je vais
j'ai vu un professeur et éclairé le
mystère d'un immense texte ça a été le
plus grand moment de ma vie
après il a mis en scène un feydeau est
un portable cette seconde là je me suis
dit hé bien il n'y a qu'une chose que je
comprends dans la vie c'est le théâtre
le cinéma les émotions le mystère des
hommes et des femmes et je vais faire ce
métier et coup de bol
j'ai fait des trucs ça a été très dur
pendant longtemps jusqu'à les nuits de
la pleine lune ou après je vais faire de
lego puisque on me reproche d'être
humble ggt duché j'ai fait des films et
ça ne manque pas de phrases comme elle
en est où la couleur de bonhomme
mouillart
c'est pas des phrases des mots qui te
manque un peu non parce qu'on attend la
couleur de la muya c'est des phrases que
tu prononcer avant dans le salon j'avais
pas cette responsabilité hiérarchique
parce que comme tu l'as dit déjà est une
voie de le roi de la piste non moi
j'étais tout simplement
voilà voilà qui veut dire voilà voilà
dans sa coiffure banon mais voila voila
il n'y a pas de cannes ans tu dis tu
prenais les pourboires tu disais quoi
bon aller pour voir ça se passait comme
ça c'est assez agréable et prenait la
monnaie comme ça mais qui monte quand
même qu'il y avait 200 vols et elle
mettait dans le jean
un très proche du sexe ou la coupe
droite et il y a
je me tirais beaucoup je vais vous dire
la vérité je me tirais beaucoup sur la
tige parce que je voyais der dette
énorme
je peux vous dire marlène jobert c'est
bien par se faire épiler
ah bon oui à la cire alors on mettait de
la cire sur leurs cuisses mais moi
j'avais des débuts très léger de culotte
blanche très douce
je sortais est alors j'allais dans mon
dans l'endroit où on se détend des et là
j'avais une super coiffeuse qui se
débloquer avec un petit shetland de
l'époque parce que c'était le rox top6
shetland tout court moi j'espérais avoir
des belles weston donc je m'étais mis
pour boire de côté pour acheter des
mocassins à 160 fois cette époque là
maintenant il faut en 2002 et est
maintenant je vais vous dire la vérité
au niveau financier je suis très bon
parti si vous voulez humainement je suis
moyen frais psychiquement assez instable
c'est seulement parce que votre âge on
disait vous n'aviez aucun charisme
section vient jouer alors votre âge en
disant mon problème avec toi je sais pas
si tu es homosexuel ou hétérosexuel ou
peut-être rien du tout tu n'as aucun
charisme s'il l'a dit ah c'est pas pour
accabler rousseau a le mec un peu
méchant ces grandes agences et c'est
déprimant 01 43
c'est déprimant quand tu rentres chez un
agent qui dit par qu'est ce qu'on va
faire de toi mon vieux je sais pas quoi
faire et que je crois que le problème ça
fait quand même quatre saints film que
tu fais une faute de demande
il n'y a pas de demande du tout du tout
et du sexe au cinéma il en faut et je
crois que j'ai compris disait-il je
pourrai jamais de prendre dans mon
agence parce qu'on ne sait pas si tu es
sexuée était déprimé alors que je suis
devenu bon ben c'est vrai que de fabrice
est vrai que les hurle je dire sur le
continent américain quand j'arrive
les femmes commencent à mettre leurs
mains près de leur sexe et y est
sur le tarmac c'est bon t'as beau nom
mais c'est je me plais beaucoup on en a
maintenant pas énormément non plus faut
pas croire ce que vous allez y menthe et
une face au mas bernard qui dit parler
c'est exagéré donc c'est évident qu'il
ya une brac par mois qui propose une
miette à moitié quand on lit ça c'est
adam agnelli qui me l'a dit donc tous
les deux mon avis est tout prêt non pas
de se fermer de se proposer comme
perspective qui propose la botte à
l'applaudît des écoutes comme c'est
peut-être qu'il nous propose mon lolo un
café a raté à un tour là mon aîné mais
est ce que vous voulez qu'on fasse une
petite interview à peine down talent à
dire ça veut dire le plus le mois on va
faire le petit jingle il faut pas bouger
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
très bien ce que vous préférez chez vous
en vous physiquement mais physiquement
et dans la tête enfin bah oui mais alors
là on rentre dans le privé pur porc mais
non non c'est des choses vraiment que je
peux pas répondre
qu'est ce que vous préférez en goût vous
allez bientôt prendre dior d'affaires ça
peut être la main droite on s'est brûlé
ça d'ailleurs les spectateurs n'ont pas
apaisé
c'est ce que vous détestez chez vous son
album que je déteste chez moi c'est tout
ce qu'on déteste tous c'est-à-dire
l'impuissance de la lâcheté l'incapacité
à être un peu ouvert d être tout ce qui
fait non dans ces personnes elles aussi
son nom ça fait 25 ans que je suis sur
un divan lui et comme daoudi allen
savall un tout petit peu mieux mais je
vais pas jusqu'à livrer les vrais
secrets
j'aime mon cachemire le plus grand
moment de votre vie jean laurent cochet
quand il a illustré et mis en lumière
une phrase mystérieuse de de feydeau et
jouissez mais vous pensez pas que c'est
quand même con labrouve de trouver dans
ce dans ce boîte de nuit angoulême est
en train de vie des premiers moments de
ma vie c'est aussi les premiers flirts
une femme de 30 ans incroyable avec une
énorme poitrine avec un chef de clan
d'incroyables m'a collé contre 1 c'était
un risque à bouhrouz beaujolais
s'étaient tenus par ben simon et pol
pacini ils sont très âgés maintenant et
je marchais j'avais quinze ces gens
avaient un jean hyper serré puis j'avais
des cars ville montante avec des boucles
que j'étais un petit minet qu'ai-je fait
très très long web nangis 48 ans donc je
suis un peu en fin de piste à cause la
revue entièrement et non menama et elle
m'a collé contre le mur et elle m'a
embrassée sur la bouche
je crois que c'est le plus beau moment
de ma vie j'ai senti une langue
on savait pas s'il fallait bouger ou
aller plus loin j'ai été immobilisé et
ça c'est un très grand moment après j'ai
mis la main sur les seins j'ai dit c'est
pas possible
et après lentement de manière inquiète
je suis descendue vers ce continent noir
c'est le champ si inquiétante sur lequel
sig moon a tellement travaillé parce que
tous les gens qui frime en disant c'est
comment je la prends moi j'y crois qu'à
moitié
gilroy qu'à moitié magalas la grand vide
et la grande vie dcexel c'est que les
mecs
les mecs sont totalement terrorisés ça
sera un autre sujet des missions les
hommes centre fabrice le pire moment de
pierre moment de ma vie
le pire moment de ma vie
c'est les fait venir un peu solennel
c'est les mauvaises les inquiétudes
quand on passe des choses un peu
inquiétante que dans le corps médical
quoi faut être simple un truc où tu
attendais réponse est entre ces les
pires moments de ta vie et puis et puis
voilà après y'a plus rien ce qui vous
fait le plus rire dans la vie
télé achat non ça c'est un peu du
conformisme de canal+
qu'est ce qui me fait trop rire virait
quand il dit jusque leblanc grand rôle
bizier didier non c'est pas du tout je
sais qui a rien pour moi dans le
prochain est ce qu'il ya vraiment rien
interroge c'est en fait parce que je
suis en train de me roger mais aussi au
départ avant les compliments j'avais pas
pensé mais non je me dis faites mais
c'est pourquoi pas ce que j'ai l'air
comme ça parce que bon j'ai été
déstabilisé mais je suis vraiment prêt
c'est ce que j'ai beaucoup d'admiration
pour toi
on m'a fait reposer même chose un rom
c'est gentil tu me donnes un grand rôle
quand même d'europe
[Applaudissements]
ces petits bals
j'ai un tempérament plutôt anxieux donc
à part quand je travaille je suis plutôt
flipper non mais attendez c'est parce
que vous êtes un set dépersonnaliser que
vous êtes un grand comédien c'est parce
que vous n'existez pas oui si vous
existiez mais moi je préfére est pernaut
le présentateur de 13h régionales
je vois prometeur qu'est ce qu'on a sur
le midi palavas bon tu va trancher la
plaza crime très jolie lettre quand j'ai
fait une hommage à carnot qui est un
moment important dans mon existence
c'est que pour moi le jour où j'ai
rencontré le 13 heures le régional j'ai
vu un grand j'ai vu un homme normal tout
va je pense que si on mettait un un
électro de bonheur entre pernaut le
présentateur du 13 heures que j'aime
beaucoup et mon truc si on pouvait nous
coller quelque chose sur l'atome ou sur
l'oeuvre sur les cuisses et qu'on dise
d'autres bonheurs 12 par exemple sur
pernod ça doit aussi les 8 9 12 14 16
moi c'est plutôt un deux au maximum sur
scène 12 13 mai ça dure une heure
quarante cinq par jour
tout le reste du temps je pense que la
vie de pernod d'ailleurs l'avis de
pernod pardonnez moi ça vous intéresse
mais vers nous
devant un porno ça nous intéresse dans
une chose très simple c'est que him a
dit c'est hallucinant parce que comment
se fait-il que vous savez comment je
rentre chez moi parce que jamais parlé
qu'en le voyant au trésor je visualise
et ça rentrait chez lui tout bas avec la
voiture j'ai fait ça fera une peugeot ou
une renault et puis que sa femme était
en train de finir
et puis quelle il arrivait pernaut qui
faisait chérie tu veux que je mette un
peu de biche
tu vois ce que je dirai la femme dit oh
merde j'ai très bien joué on ne quitte
jamais allée gilet à laraque et ça c'est
un enthousiasme est vital au niveau
spinosi rien pas même mitch a il faut
quand même ne pas être dépressif pour
entrer après le boulot et dire à sa
femme je fais un peu de buch et la femme
fait en tout genre de plaisanterie ou el
sheikh et c'était drôle balai magique
apparent kim et la bûche et puis après
il fait mr je vais garder la bagnole il
va garer la bagnole il revient ça c'est
un être qui va bien il n'a pas lu
spinoza il n'a pas lu niche
j'envie totalement pernaut j'en fais pas
un cheval de bataille médiatique
on
prosternés je reste j'accueille
maintenant philippe sollers
philippe sollers bonsoir bonsoir charme
du service public ne pouvant accueillir
les écrivains le samedi soir la
télévision
je crois qu'il faut s'en féliciter mais
oui je vous remercie d'être là je vous
en prie mais c'est moi j'ai un petit
truc pour vous
[Musique]
ça c'est le vôtre un celui de chabat
alors philippe sollers vous publier
l'aïe de proust chez stock
c'est très étonnant parce que je sais
pas si vous connaissez ça fabrice mais
zoug manga sans proust dessinée regardez
c'est très étonnant
l'espèce de griffonnages cessa de
gribouillages dans la marre d'avoir
l'idée simplement un jour c'était tout
simple de les réunir ensemble ouais pour
voir que c'est pas seulement dans les
manuscrits mais aussi dans les lettres
qu'ils adressent notamment reynaldo hahn
est là avec il a une correspondance très
très dur y est très très important parce
que l'on voit qu'ils copient des tas de
choses au départ ils s'intéressent
beaucoup à emile mâle à la religieuse
s'introduit dans dans les cathédrales
c'est un drôle de type
et puis après les personnages commencent
à apparaître et tous les personnages de
la recherche du temps perdu
les hommes femmes les femmes hommes etc
etc
les oiseaux qui s'est un peu petit un
peu comme si vous avez ça avant de
chercher l'hémophilie c'est à dire en
même temps d'en trouver le mot en même
temps il ya il écrit l'effet de chance
et puis et puis quel une figure se
détache aime bien comme ça dans la marge
ou en plein manuscrits tout à coup et on
voit des êtres bizarres qui sont à la
limite de l'animalité souvent c'est ça
souvent prous les êtres humains ont
tendance à retomber animaux souvent en
oiseaux ils ont des becs qui se vont se
faire du mal ils ont des grimaces but
étrange
en tout cas c'est un formidable
éclairage sur le sur l'avs je trouve ça
se permet de le lire d'autant que ce
n'est pas mal fait céder les citations
qui arrive la recherche du temps perdu
en regard des dessins et ça permet de
voir que ça me sall visualise mieux à
mon avis beaucoup mieux que les
photographies et surtout que les écolos
cinéma quand on fait jouer en faveur
d'un brusque comme ça c'est à dire si
c'est beaucoup moins passer beaucoup
mais beaucoup moins
je kitsch que tous les efforts pour
présenter projet il ya plus de cruauté
dans les dessins vous publiez un autre
bouquin qui s'appelle un amour américain
mensuel est tout petit il faut vraiment
zoom est fort tout l'été pour vous
faites des trucs comme ça s'achète une
nouvelle voici une nouvelle voie là
c'est aux éditions mille et une nuits ça
s'appelle la mort américains seront bien
différents qui seront voilà et c'est oui
j'ai pacifique
c'est un amour entre un français de 32
ans il américaine de 26 ans elisa une
new yorkaise
c'est pour moi les rapports entre la
france et la mairie qui sont pas et qui
sont pas extraordinaires comme vous
savez top ce bonnet latéralement il peut
y avoir des histoires sur l'oreiller
vous pensez que c'est possible ça d oui
bien sûr mais quand même à localisable
vous êtes toujours ailleurs là où vous
attend ça j'espère aussi donné un mal de
chien puisque non je vais il suffit
d'être un peu chiant si vous donnez
l'impression de zapper un peu sur vos
sur vos différentes existence euros je
crois pas ils croient qu'ils ne gagnent
ténacité il ya une cohérence ou fricker
soirs où ça prend du temps c'est donc ce
nom il ya une cohérence dans vos prises
de position dans vos fidélités
successives vous pensez qu'il ya une qui
a une cohérence
oui parce que le l'image sociale comme
dit procédure ne savait il est l'image
que les autres font de vous une image
sociale c'est us et leur construction a
eu oui n'en est pas vraiment responsable
ce qui est intéressant c'est de
continuer à écrire voilà donc là dessus
il ya les pages qui s'entassent celui ça
finit par faire des livres et puis au
final on disparaît puis les libres reste
espérons enfin un peu de temps vous avez
commencé avec des choses on va regarder
en vitesse mais c'est intéressant parce
que j'ai commencé avec un bouquin assez
classique qui s'appelait une curieuse
solitude donc pas eu le défi avant mais
disons le premier qui a été remarquée
c'était une création
[Musique]
ça c'est sexy c'est lui à la fois par
mauriac catholique et par aragon
communiste le kremlin le vatican donc
déjà il y avait sept cette dualité
et puis après ça c'était un style assez
classique après vous vous vous lancez
dans le nouveau roman vous annoncer la
fin de la littérature traditionnelle ont
déjà premiers rudiments d'une certaine
façon me pour échapper à des
appropriations comme celle là mauriac
arabes ont cherché une progéniture une
filiation il fallait leur semble et il
croyait que j'allais faire ça j'ai fait
autre chose mais avant de s'échapper il
faut faire ce qu'on veut voilà en gros
ça va être très long on va il faut y
aller très vite sur votre carrière non
mais si on va faire ça non mais je vous
propose qu'on fasse une liste de tous
vos rudiments successifs à bord ont
suivi c'est pourquoi reniement reniement
parce que vous êtes donc d'abord dans
l'évasion plus tôt peut-être oui
échappements
si on veut oui alors là il ya donc
l'époque de nouveaux romans où vous
faites quand même 20 ans d'expérience
sur le langage écrit un bouquin qui
s'appelle paradis sans point virgule
après vous passez au maoïsme oui enfin
si vous voulez comme ça oui bon on va
pas loin après enfin vous il faut
l'époque suppose quand même de grands
bouleversements il faut mettre ça dans
l'histoire mais il assure salle à manger
ses 68 ans quand on vous parle du
maoïsme on vous dit vous avez été
maoïste alors ils ont dit oui mais c'est
une attitude esthétique que c'est de
l'humour
le livre réalisme socialiste avait
pataphysique et ses amants fazul et
quand on connaît des crimes de
de maoussa n'est ce pas vrai vers l'azur
vous avez bien raison il faut les
condamner ce très sévèrement et même
sans arrêt ah non non je suis lancé à
ses anciens staliniens qui disent
c'était terrible sterling sauf que
l'époque ils l'adorent et quand même
vrai oui je crois qu'il ya une grande
différence entre staline et mao c'est
vrai moi j'essaye de convaincre les gens
depuis très longtemps que les que les
chinois ne sont pas des russes mais j'ai
échoué chameau personne de ben écoute
alors vous dites aussi moi j'étais
maryse parce que c'était une attitude
justement antisoviétique c'est à dire je
crois qu'on pouvait enfin sauf que moi
j'ai retrouvé une phrase que à une
phrase de vous en ou de 68 au moment où
l'armée rouge envahi prague au g8 la
nature pour vous mon cher ami dans la
place beauvau vous dites
inutile de vous dire qu'il ne faut pas
compter sur moi pour désarmer ne serait
ce qu'une seconde l'armée rouge
oui c'est dans quel contexte quel moment
je peux si tu vas de vous nathalie ça
chez le coiffeur de cela très bien c'est
très bien c'est très mal d'accord off
c'est bien sûr disque est incroyable
avec sollers et qu'il est inattaquable
mais dans ce cas quelque chose du doigt
et c'est vrai j'ai dit ça c'est quand
même pas bien et c'est pas bien vous
voulez me faire dire que ce que c'est
bien non c'est pas bien non je vais
simplement ce dont je me suis aperçu en
prêt pendant ce procès c'est le procès
des écrivains ce serait une chose ça
serait un sujet à traiter
je crois qu'on peut faire le procès
après la guerre il ya eu pas mal de
procès d'écrivain oui et puis et puis
oui
l'écrivain est quelqu'un qui est que
vous voyez n'arrête pas de n'arrête pas
de se tromper
non mais peut-être pas dans celle entre
la guerre on a en a on a jugé des
écrivains pour collaboration on en
jugera avec l'hitlérisme ce qui était
pratiqué de ce que tu erbate tous les
autres n'ont pas il ya jamais les vins
jugé pour pour stalinisme en même temps
c'est dommage on devrait le faire
vous savez qu'avec une phrase comme ça
vous pouvez lantheaume voyez bien bon
pour maryse casanova oui peut-être mais
c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'il n'était pas
bien vue de l'acquisition à venir quand
j'étais tellement après le marine vous
devenez votre qg tout vous devenez pas
piste comme vous y allez oui enfin oui
mais toujours pour les mêmes raisons
c'est-à-dire tout ce qui peut
déstabiliser bien papistes parce qu'on
peut on peut être chrétien on peut on
peut améliorer la parole du christ mais
papy c'est autre chose pas pis c'est
qu'on vénère le pape c'est là vous êtes
vous est de cet avis moi oui mais c'est
pas moi que saviez-vous
alors vous ne venez pas piste mais non
seulement glisser dans l'âme et libertin
jeu là d'un coup voilà où nous fêtons
part d'un coup je l'étais déjà mais on
ne devient les femmes vous revenez à une
forme lisible l'horizon ah oui enfin
pour les gens comme moi évidemment
wallon ex mao donc devenu papistes
libertin évidemment alors en 95
longtemps tout sachez que je vous
reproche en 95 vous tenez balladuriens
ah non merci
vous écrivez un bouquin que ça paiera
pas qu'un article de bouc du repas pour
camille comme un article qui s'appelle
balladur tel quel alors là j'aurais dû
mettre des points d'ironie en effet mais
d'ailleurs pour tout ce que j'ai fait
ouais je crois que le
la question maintenant l'ironie se
perdant et qu'on va mettre chaque fois
attention et elle ironisé la mi-mai
quand vous déjà du mal de me débrouiller
défendez balladur comme tout
intelligentsias et toute la nomenclature
à française de l'époque à commencer par
bernard henri lévy alain minc
il était de bon ton à l'époque des
balladuriens et chiraquiens jeux
présentés en lui un destin tragique
vous vous dites que balladur a été
victime de xénophobie parce qu'il est
d'origine turque franchement s'il ya
quelqu'un qui a installé dans le système
et qui quand on se fout qu'ils
souhaitent turcs ou pas c'est bien parce
que j'avais pas lu tout ce qu'on disait
sur lui l'étrangleur ottoman c'est vrai
qu'il a un côté look ou un peu plus
qu'avant mais voilà ça sera vite voilà
ya l'europe ce n'est pas comme le bon
13e apreva la dure n'est pas élu donc
c'est chirac élu contre vous vont se
souhaita temps on feb vive la cantine
trouve que sur le plan politique cette
gamme systématiquement trompée
oui un même si je sais que j'y tiens les
noms mais ça je trouve ça plutôt
sympathique les gens qui se trompent en
politique chez kia toujours iraizoz four
est pas encore là vous faites vous
faites un article qui a un énorme
retentissement dans le monde qui
s'appelle la france moisie et quand on
lit ce papier d'ailleurs on n'est pas
loin de d'entendre la france nazis dire
que c'est un à six c'est un article
disons anti anti familia rist
antinationaliste assez violent ou dans
ce que vous décrivez une france disons
qu'ils seraient celles que rêve dont
rêvent peut-être philippe de villiers
enfin voilà c'est tout beaucoup de gens
ouais villiers pasqua châsse d'edouard
le pen mégret rondes douces et voilà
c'est à dire que si on additionne tout
ça en fait on arrive à l'histoire de ce
pays qui
qui a eu quand même des problèmes en
1940 puis lisa qui est symbolisé jadot
les digérer mais de façon enfin
mitterrand tout ça bousquet or voilà bon
vous allez gens portent sur vous
effectivement suite à ce que je viens de
dire on peut avoir sur vous des avis
extrêmement partagés alors il ya ya
bernard henri lévy qui lui est très
laudatif
votre égard il dit sollers et le plus
grands écrivains contemporains par aof
comme mitterrand avait dit joe raison
lui alors ça ça m'a aussi dit que son
film était excellent donc pour en
prendre les sépare donc lui lui il est
plutôt plutôt positif sur nokia des
projets des projets dit il parle d'un
plafond il dit ce plafond dont la totale
platitude n'est pas sans évoquer les
plus belles pages de philippe sollers
une cassette siens qui sort de desproges
vous êtes dedans
bon bah on va le regarder on va regarder
un extrait samuel et ambra magnéto
coluche et était un petit peu un petit
peu sagouin par certains côtés c'était
pince simone signoret n'était pas si
belle il faut bien regarder les photos
de près elle n'est pas si belle qu'on
l'a dit après sa mort scharenberg n'est
pas non plus n'a pas non plus dorée hall
pour moi il en aurait pu s'y passer plus
de temps dans son hôpital que les
studios de télé je remettrai son auréole
mais pour l'instant je n'ai pas ce qui
me gonfle le sacré parce que quand on
quand on se met à du lait le sacré on
est toujours un petit peu à munich en 33
ou au stade du heysel ya deux ans je me
heurte parfois à une telle
incompréhension de la part de mes
contemporains qu un épouvantable doute
mais train suis-je bien de cette planète
dur dur à ceux du marais durable
l'apologiste sénile des infanticides
ruraux
marguerite duras qui n'a pas écrit que
des conneries
elle en a aussi filmé comprenons nous
bien je ne prendrai pas mon père a
marché certes je ne donnerai pas non
plus mes poupées le pen
on serait capable de les torturer ce
conte
vous n'êtes que cet homme là n'est pas
humain je suis sûr qu'il ya plus
d'humanité dans l'oeil d'un chien quand
il remue la queue dans la queue de le
pen pinter remis son oeil
mes projets alors il ya tout un tas de
gens allaient en libérateurs sans toit
ni de koné puis à tout un tas de gens de
tout un tas d'acteurs dont vous qui
dites me souviens visé des textes et des
extraits de droit de réponse du petit
rapporteur et c'est vous la voulez vous
lui en voulez pas de même pas du tout
d'accord si ça d'avoir dit que
finalement ce plafond sera toujours la
platitude n'est pas sans évoquer les
plus belles pages des choses comme il
les avait pas lui c'est pas grave il a
la chance que vous allez c'est qui peut
pas répondre mais voilà non je sais pas
on se demande toujours moi je vous
connais mais les gens se demandent
toujours si vous êtes une pesée pas une
fausse valeur fait moins qui sortent sur
l'heure du temps et qui est un grand
écrivain l'ancienneté que dire que
l'ambiguïté
on ne sort de l'ambiguïté qu'à son
détriment radis quelqu'un ah oui alors
on va parler des femmes un peu non là
aussi il ya deux versions de votre
version avoue dans l'année du ticket
votre journal de l'année 98 paru au
seuil
l'influent site j'ai eu au moins dix
fois des propositions de fellation de la
part de filles de 20 ans ça c'est votre
affirmation
oui c'est banal se marie pas un métier
c'est à pigalle donc à aucun moment je
fais tout ce que je peux pourtant je
fais de la radio ils font rien alors
justement la baisse et pour ça je me
montre sous mon meilleur jour ce malgré
des landes est un jeu que la proposition
vient à moi j'ai rien compris
est ce que vous vous avez déjà une fois
les propositions de fellation de la part
de l'électricien dans son journal le la
part de filles de 20 ans j'ai moi
c'était un autographe
donc ça va parler - malheureusement il
fait alors ça c'est votre version qui a
pris à houellebecq alors je dis pas qui
parle de il parle pas de vous parce que
c'est un roman donc il dit simplement
dans les particules élémentaires où
j'apparais oui il dit en parlant de vous
un il ne réussissait à des personnages
qui sait ce personnage qui dit ça on est
bien d'accord
il dit non ça n'a pas eu lieu elle était
saine n'a pas eu lieu mais quand même il
dit en parlant de vous non mais les
raisons de le préciser il ne réussissait
à tringles et que de vieilles [ __ ]
appartenant aux milieux culturels les
mines est visiblement préfère les
chanteurs oui alors ça c'est le
narrateur de houellebecq y avait en
effet des problèmes de communication et
image inc au final entre les deux
versions vous maintenez j'étais
finalement je me vanter que ce fait
voilà vous maintenez la lumière qu'il a
raison ouais on sait jamais avec lui on
va faire un vous allez voir que ça c'est
pour vous on va faire un concours de
citation attention ça s'appelle qui a
dit aimer les femmes intelligentes est
un plaisir de pédéraste haute charlie
baudelaire à et c'est l'amour c'est
l'infini à la portée des caniches of
course à l'essai ouais céline des
touches au paradis on était assis à la
droite de dieu c'est normal si la place
du mort tu as clichés quasi ça c'est pas
tes proches
ouais c'est bien essayé des concours de
citations et bien comme houssin bonnart
on en rouge et noir j'exigerai marshall
wace sur 1000mercis passion vraiment
rouge et noir j'exigerai mapper j'irai
plus haut que les montagnes de douleurs
j'aime la phrase impérissable attention
continue jeu conviendrait bien
volontiers que les femmes nous sont
supérieures si cela pouvait les
dissuader de se prétendre noé gaza
pourrait du tri guy qui a dit la sodomie
relance le couple non c'est pas lui qui
giclait non c'est vrai ou pas c'est vrai
c'est laurence cochet personnes
la france est assez obscures est ce que
cette phrase va relancer laurence cochet
est-ce que qui a dit la dictature c'est
ferme ta gueule et la démocratie c'est
cause toujours
mao tse tôt non tout ça vous devriez le
savoir
non chabal je suis nouveau idole enfin
j'espère je sais des proches non la
dictature c'est ferme ta gueule et la
démocratie c'est cause toujours
si je vous dis allen il a dit aussi pour
bien faire l'amour à sa femme pour
s'entraîner longtemps tout seul qui a
dit la culture c'est comme les
parachutes quand on en a pas on s'écrase
proche ça va croiser dieu n'existait pas
il faudrait l'inventer
photoshop j'ai très très connu non c'est
pas nietzsche c'est panique je vais
or c'est voltaire
oui j'allais justement que voltaire est
une très belle chose là dessus sur sur
nietzsche qui dit là je suis jaloux pour
toujours d'ailleurs je vous ai apporté
une lettre pour vous pour finir les
missions vers les actions il ya une très
très belle je sais je suis jaloux pour
toujours de stendhal dit nietzsche car
ce grand ce grand amateur de musique de
chambre de l'âme aap on a créé une
intuition que je n'aurais jamais eu
c'est je crois je cite mal
la seule excuse pour dieu sait qu'il
n'existe pas ça c'est donc snitch citant
souvent stade 1 qui a dit je suis je
suis athée dieu merci
woody allen stendhal et qui a dit je
n'existe pas tout le monde
spinoza le premier sera une à paul du
temps mais ça s'est passé ce que va dire
la maintenant il a dit la rue moreau il
aurait menti alors partout chez spinoza
m'aurait menti
qui a dit de tous les vices le pire et
l'excès de vertu je ne sais pas
le général de gaulle philippe de
villiers j'avais mis en exergue d'un
livre aussi en signant sénèque et tout
le monde avait dit formidable la
citation de sénèque quand même bon on
termine avec quand les mouettes suivent
un chalutier c'est qu'elles savent que
les sardines seront jetées à la mer
eric cantona bravo comprend des auteurs
les enfants on va faire on va se
souvenir de l'époque où fabrice luchini
était animateur de boîte de nuit en
guadeloupe est allé faire angoulême
d'ailleurs parce que vous étiez à paris
dans vos salons de coiffure avenue
montaigne et puis d'un coup alors
ghoulem parce qu'il demandait un
animateur pour la soul music pour parler
de james brown et de wilson pickett
lycées mendel d'arthur connaulais
d'aretha franklin
donc il y avait la danse à cette époque
là qui était très important à les années
68 69 69 et déjà et donc comme ils
avaient besoin d'un animateur
donc j'étais angoulême pour rien doctor
d'accord
[Musique]
bon ça c'est de la hune test alors on y
va didier alors vous attendez vous
connaissez le principe donc tout le
monde joue d'accord à la première il
faut reconnaître les chansons à la
première note
sinon c'est ringard ça c'est arthur tout
d'un coup c'est la condition pour quoi
des fois redit son tweet ses premiers ça
ça je les fais dans un bain de minuit
dans les lettres noires il ya mieux
disant we want est roi de la piste blind
est bon on y va didier généreux et
didier gainsbourg 26 sec 5 100 d'accord
l'internet a répondu que numéro 3 didier
[Musique]
travers des soufflets michael
vous souvenez pas sinon je fais évacuer
la salle didier numéro quatre chercheurs
ça c'est une blague de spécial chez lui
oh
fête mariale soutien
70 là je vous tiens
[Musique]
non sans mal on ne pouvait pas trouver
écouter la voix arrive un îlot nogaro
non manhattan transfer narp
[Musique]
c'est dur michel aumont
barbara a on s'approche
c'est une vieille dame li no way non
vous avez vu la fiche c'est ma voisine
line renaud
j'ai poussé disque est suspect non mais
tu verras tu es une demande non parce
qu'on vous présente quelques atouts dans
mado m20 qu'albi vous avez été le voisin
de le pen n'avait pas tous se disent non
plus ah non ça j'ai des ménages alma
numéro 5 didier s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
salt and pepper la bouche
betts tokamak sexe oui mais à mon sens
quelque part oui radiesthésie
ça rappelle alors angoulême
c'est effectivement salt n pepa
l'estomac marque sec suivant
m
plus d'une
oui
indochine troisième sexe l'année c'est
que quoi quel rapport avec celle qu'elle
suit la sas et nicolas oui non mais
c'est quel titre part d'un troisième
sexe à part donc d'indochine et que
c'est que je suis comme solaire c'était
la situation des chansons qui connaît
parce que j'avoue m'être que doublé ces
mêmes blues tout le formidable wilson
pickett quand on attaque le premier
qu'on a trouvé james on voit bien quand
même que le reste manque d'une certaine
vitalité organique et libidinale
pourquoi james doit on est très
important parce qu'il arrive à faire de
l'afrique et de l'amérique un lien un
pont une sorte de pourquoi tolérant
grands chanteurs de mad men blues sont
exceptionnels c'est parce qu'il ya
quelque chose de l'ordre de du pourquoi
il est le seul à faire un débat tout
voir les pathétiques mais quand ils vont
dans les boîtes un jour je ferai un
spectacle à dessus mais ça je fais
penser à l'élection la danse des mecs
qui essaye de faire comme les blagues ce
jeune et sublime de drôlerie pénale
parce que je pense que la fête est pas
fait pour les occidentaux
je vais préférer la joue très grave
tant qu'on est là c'est pathétique quand
les gens font la fête c'est patrick sont
pas faits pour ça
la seule fête c'est un truc seul tout
seul tu mets un disque tout seul tu tues
esquisse n'avions pas mais quand les
occidentaux sont et à faire des
africains étaient touchés parce que les
meufs sont pas rouler comme ça parce que
les mecs sont pas bien
aaron kampman karman
bongo
à vélo
la star c'est pas bon et ça sort good
bonbons agadou osé toucher jumping c'est
déjà un scandale alors j'ai tellement
d'amour pour jane et son importante
importants de l'époque de stacks
l'époque des grands 33 tours formidable
tout ça j'adorais cette époque là
j'adore devant vous il ya deux choses
c'est l'obsession des gauchistes qui
vous ont accablé pendant des années des
brisants vous êtes et un réacteur
monarchie ça donc à chaque fois vous
replacez je fais scheer amis mais vous
avez quand même fait un procès hyper
content maintenant que les idéologies
sont mortes le père a redit son ironie
vas-y après deuxième question deuxième
question c'est qui le préférait est-ce
que c'est arthur caunes les 13 à une
carte steve cropper
alors je pense que wilson pickett est un
immense immense chanteur de rythm and
blues
je pense que james brown est très varié
je pensais à deleuze qui parlait des
grands écrivains et qu'il disait deleuze
disait deleuze disais pourquoi les
grandes caisses que celles des grandes
craintes et ceux qui travaillent tout le
temps dont qui cite évidemment les
éternels sedin procès
enfin surtout céline puisque ça
changeait inlassablement dans la dans le
travail et il est une farce très belle
de l'eau sur la gauche il disait qu'un
gouvernement ne peut jamais de gauche le
truc banal assez l'abécédaire et tout ça
en cassette je le conseille comme les
deschiens conseil à l'abécédaire de
deleuze suprême en gamme renault chez
quand on s'appelle bruno nous serons là
peuvent être payés à temps la gauche
c'est la résistance et surtout
l'opposition et ya une chose magnifique
on lui dit ah dommage mais c'est quoi
pour vous être de gauche il répond c'est
simplement penser que le monde commence
pam dans ma rue mais commence très très
loin très très loin et la droite il le
dit vachement bien je vois pas du tout -
rejouait poncifs turcot nature connaît
malheureusement il a pas là des jeunes
et des autres a dit carla thomas carla
thomas très très beau trompe avec otis
redding puissance de l'incompréhension
homme femme très important à relever
avec coolio tu là là tout de suite
proches des bords de youphil et tuteurs
et chats et bien alors on peut pas
travailler sérieusement
si on continue chanson numéro 7
alors justement elle va lancer sa vie
cachée son père voilà
et voilà quand tu lis bien le ring aïe
aïe aïe ya neuf ans en plus franches qui
fait ça l'amossois la meuf en blouse
blanche qui disent ça et l'autre qui
fait la lie à la la pièce qui monte et
le clip mais très ragga rang ce qui est
très drôle c'est que art
otis redding était géniale et je n'avais
pas le thunder naissent les normes
shedden avait pas ça c'est ce qui m'a
dit non c'est le mec qui parle de ce
même neige comme de spinoza jsk m'a dit
c'est même dave j'aimerais que tu
comprennes bien ce qui va se passer pour
toi parce que je comprends pas pourquoi
je fais ça gratos
parce que là je suis en train de donner
un énorme truc c'est mes modèles j'ai eu
le contact avec lui un jour c'est ma vie
j'ai eu le contact d'accord et t2 et
home so sur le même voilà c'est me l'a
dit otis c'était moi j'en je mets du
lyrisme il ya du rimbaud un petit peu
disparu où il a disparu très tôt dans un
avion c'est là on peut philosopher faire
des émissions de 10 heures pourquoi un
mec avait cette voix qui bougeait page
et j'ose dire une petite limite ne
bougeais pas bien du tout lotus était
étonnant otis il est hyper grands c'est
une espèce d'homme il bouge très
normalement sur la scène tu vois james
blonde à faire la même époque il bouge
sur un pied c'est prodigieux etc
et alors il ya un truc génial c'est que
tu as this trading meurt à quel h 23 il
meurt dans un accident d'avion et tout
son orgueil et quel est le bien est
disque de
kobe et qu'est ce qui se passe au
sifflement il ya un sifflement lacets
mendez qui était très lyrique a dit
c'est la descente de l'avion j'ai dit tu
devrais écrire alors bassin chanson
numéro 9 didier
le
l'ebita jouer
sexy ça dit ouais ben saada sexy sadi
saïbi les beatles dernière chance aura
tout vu mais si tout art chinois petit
jeu c'est bien le sexe et des infections
mais là c'est un peu ça laisse tourner
les survoler son savoir faire dans la
vie
par exemple les blacks c'est la seule à
savoir perdre arias ma jeune très très
mal au gardien
j'ai ça dans la tête qui par là nous on
sait pas le faire nous on est là pendant
20 années à les observer ne sait pas
faire
il est quand même il est comme le
l'autre blanc qui a chanté avec 2,9
mam john mayer j'aime quand c'est les
seuls dont la voix avec les animals
je tiens à dire à la ce soir à lens il
faut qu'on fasse un spécial
il faut faire un spécial il a fort à qui
est énorme au service public mois c'est
énorme mais ils vont mettre de la
monnaie écoute bien il ya un truc
important à dire ce soir aux autres de
lire le livre de philippe soler je
voudrais qu'on fasse un zoom s'il vous
plaît et en même temps la cassette
d'al-hasaba les briques en vigueur
il faut faire ça faut aller voir le film
d'alain chabat qui va sortir une
incroyable shabbat en génie alors ils y
ont duré label guillaume qui pourra
alors il y a une chose il faut que les
gens achètent gloria de mdm ça c'est un
très grand moment je donne je t'adore du
type connaît c'est génial vous convient
pas ensemble graf qui est en train de se
passer bien l'aveu d'un homme installé
financièrement stable qui fait du sport
dans un hôtel connu avec les autres avec
moi et qui est en train de révéler ce
que sollers crient à tue tête comme
adamo parce que comme a dit laurent
baffie un jour ou l'autre
adamo arrive car adamo a dit je veux
crier ton nom c'est important et bien
maintenant ce que sollers avait prévu
c'est à dire des mimiques et j'adore
adamo mais je me souviens pas de celle
là précisément peu connue elle s'appelle
je veux crier tout nous crier sans
remords que même un compagnon c'est mon
amour si fort je veux crier ton nom
crier sans remords mais là c'est vrai
c'est vrai que je vais finir par ne plus
aller à la télé que pour chanter et
loire qui jacques heure là maintenant
jaked est un type ils meurent à parler
politique
maintenant vous allez voir c'est un la
page 9 là c'est fini
oui mais lindahl mines distant comme on
voit bien train de gagner du temps
lol
alors voilà jean louis angel je vous
présente fabrice luchini ans philippe
sollers al-hasaba vous êtes dans du gros
là là là c'est du lourd c'est du lourd
un jour là c'est du lourd
ce n'est pas fille vous avez la femme et
dans l'asie
jean-louis ça va tellement sensibilité
alors là bas justement là justement que
là je crois que là il ya là justement
alors on a en a parlé des reniements
successifs on a parlé des reniements
successifs de philippe sollers qui pour
un écrivain après tout c'est la moindre
des choses sont maintenant on va parler
des remaniements de jean-louis jones et
dans leur dernière fois que je vous ai
eu sur ce plateau seilhac je sais pas
c'était à la famille je suis ya très
longtemps
faut qu'ils arrêtent dit m timide non
merci à vous comprennez croyez moi non
mais parce que l'aja aucune raison à la
défense
quel que soit son parti politique on a
envie d'aller avec lui là il arrive des
prix mais là il arrive ce genre urbain
bon alors la dernière fois que je les ai
reçus sur sur ce plateau 1
vous étiez patron du sgpc le syndicat
général de la poule à la police voilà et
vous étiez un policier attendait la
pensée correcte caldwell peut vous faire
sauter des pv enfin plumes assorti
alors vous étiez vous vous étiez un
policier républicain disons anti anti fn
d'ailleurs vous avez demandé à l'époque
la dissolution du service d'ordre du fn
le fameux dpl si vous êtes membre en
faisait à l'époque un supporter de volée
peu plus que maintenant je comprends pas
ce qui se passe vous étiez membre d'une
association plutôt laïcarde qui
s'appelle le réseau voltaire ain et est
membre du grand orient soit vous l'avez
dit on peut le dire on le dit pour moi
oui on l'a dit pour vous mais j'ai c'est
une réalité
c'est une réalité vous êtes un ancien
d'état fut un ancien des jeunesses
pourquoi chez lui où julian oui hommage
aux prud'hommes
je connais pas d'en face à payet là tous
enfin un ancien des jeunesses
communistes dans ses agissements
six mois mais c'est pas prêt tout seul r
ç'a bien été maoïste et reçoit des
parfaits nobody's perfect donc ancien
militant socialiste aussi ça fait un
petit passage au ps
et alors vous étiez quand même assez
virulent parce que vous êtes élevé par
exemple contre le financement de la
cathédrale d'evry par jack lang en
disant que l'état français est enfin là
publique française n'avait pas à
financer les cathédrales
no coment ensuite vous vous êtes élevé
contre la montée du fn
organisée par la gauche pas tous ah bon
on voit très bien merci à toi et rend
passionnant mais tout ça est le nom
était rajol très cohérent flic
républicain patron de syndicats francs
macs voilà enfin bon hélas alors là vous
nous expliquer en même temps un mail à
vous êtes candidat rpf c'est à dire
pasqua/villiers à l'élection législative
partielle du 20e à paris 1 qui a lieu le
28 novembre deuxième tour le 5 décembre
par mois je vous pose une question
aujourd'hui c'est la seule en fait j'ai
vraiment envie de vous poser ce soir à
prêter de tir
est-ce que vous restez vigilants mais
est ce que vous pensez pas que votre
grand père anarchistes espagnols
condamné à mort par le régime de franco
va se retourner dans sa tombe vous voir
vous fâchez pas être candidat pour le
parti de philippe de villiers
ça j'y comprends plus rien - non mais
moi je crois que ceux qui doivent se
retourner dans leur tombe aujourd'hui
c'est plutôt jean jaurès où le général
de gaulle quoi bon moi je crois avoir
toujours été républicain
donc j'ai eu un parcours parce qu'il est
issu d'une famille de gauche dont j'aime
beaucoup à gauche qu'à droite c'est
évidemment mais je crois très
sincèrement aujourd'hui et je les
considérais aux syndicats que la gauche
et la droite ne veut plus rien dire
qu'il existe des républicains duncan
qu'il existe des républicains à l'autre
et qu'il est grand temps de les
rassembler c'est ce qui a fait que je me
suis engagé aux côtés de charles pasqua
qui a la même optique que mon à ce
domaine voilà aussi simple que ça alors
votre première rencontre avec pasqua et
vous a dit c'est pas un casier que vous
avez au verger c'est un immeuble
ouais ça c'est la première fois que
louis matte est ce que vous n'êtes pas
un peu tenu c'est pas parce que
peut-être qu'il avait sûrement si la
mennais dossier sûrement chevènement ou
les meubles pour faire ils se les
passent après
pasqua bien sûr seule différence est que
chevènement n'est pas allé jusqu'au bout
de ses convictions il a simulé le coma
pour pas développer des dossiers
maintenant attendez d'en sérieusement
quand deux bons pasqua
c'est bien ce que le faire pasqua pasqua
il veut pas être classé à droite donc ça
fait déjà des des mois et des mois qui
cherche des gens un peu
venant de la gauche pour montrer qu'il
est pas de droite sauf qu'il y
lavilliers ville il apporte quand même
au parti 8 millions de francs par an
donc ce pognon on passe quoi il peut pas
cracher dessus non plus hein je sais pas
du tout comment je peux vous dire que
fumer comme panneau électoral que c'est
pas évident au final j'ai bien et très
sûr enfin vide il est quand même anti 35
heures anti pacs non mais si vous voulez
thierry moi je crois qu'aujourd'hui cas
vous mettez cinq ou six françaises une
pièce ils sont tous différents et c'est
normal et puis tant mieux je veux tenir
bon et je crois que les 35 heures je
crois que le pacs je crois que tous ces
sujets qui sont à mes yeux accessoires
par rapport à l'essentiel de dire
qu'elle est l'amie euros
y'a pas que l'apéro mais l'apéro 7ème
porta aussi c'est au moins un espace de
convivialité
mais l'essentiel c'est qu'il ya encore
aujourd'hui à ce pays 6 à 7 millions
souvent de gauche français qui vit dans
la précarité
l'essentiel c'est que ces pays
aujourd'hui en baisse par exemple le
taux du livret vous savez d'epargne
populaire de 3 à 2,25 et qu'on pénalise
ainsi des français les plus modestes
assez pâle droite qu'il a fait c'est la
gauche
ce gip est absolument rien quand vous
mettez une loi sur les 35 heures est la
première est aussi de diviser la france
moi je constate donc que je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il faut gommer nos
différences parce qu'on en a grand
besoin que la situation de la france est
dramatique et qu'il faut rassembler les
français non résidents sur ce qui les
rassure louis l'hydromel des valeurs de
gauche
de villiers s'est pas cohn-bendit pour
moi c'est pas exactement la même chose
même escroquerie liée c'est quand même
je vais dire pour moi il est vraiment
extrêmement extrêmement à droite mais
franchement bon moi je pense que
philippe de villiers il est à droite
pourquoi parce qu'il défend certaines
valeurs et qui là je dirais comme la
famille etc
s'il défend bref la miss être de droite
moi j'estime que je défende la famille
soit pour autant que le suis de droite
droite je veux dire je crois qu'il ya
des valeurs aujourd'hui qui
n'appartiennent ni à la droite ni à la
gauche
tout ce qu'il faut et valeurs de droite
il faut de façon développer à droite qui
sont pas développés à gauche même si
c'est le bordel et on comprend pas là
rien et tout ça mais d'un seul coup dire
c'est le bordel on comprend plus rien et
faire on va faire un truc qui n'est ni
droite ni gauche ni bâbord ni tribord
français d'abord machin espèce de mach
un peu flou comme ça moi je fais ce que
je ressens lorsque je dis je joue plus
je franchement j'adore
excusez moi dès le haka justement aux
morts immédiatement il vous a pas
interrompu tout à l'heure c'est
justement pour pour un petit peu ex
préciser ce que dit alain chabat voulons
pasqua bon il ya quand même dans ce
parti rpf et quand marciani oui je le
préfet là le fameux march yannick est
quand même pas bon il ya tard et lee qui
était l'adjoint au maire de simonpieri
alain tarlier adjoint au maire de
simonpieri à marignane
bon il ya un dénommé crespin alors
est-ce qu'on n'est pas en train de faire
un peu les bras
sous les roses brun est ce qu'on n'est
pas en train de faire le rpf de d'oriola
le ppf pardon de doriot et il ya plein
de gens qui venaient du parti socialiste
et qui sont tous retrouvés
collaborateurs en 40 dont tout cas ce
qui me concerne je crois avoir démontré
dans les actes et donc par les propos
que tout ce qui touche à l'extrême
droite ou partir là je vais remettre les
micros de fabriquer ce qui se bat
juridiquement
moi c'est une excuse et moi jean louis
mais là c'est la première fois que je la
vois comme ça c'est qu'elle se lève et
se jette sur l'invité soin de nous
inviter il faut 4 ipod iphone 4 ipod ça
c'est tout linda
elle n'est pas venu pour rien luchini
finalement s'arrangera le nom de la
maison poulaga occupent le haut du filet
comme ça la ville et je suis harcelé
misery quoi bon alors al assaba on en
est au coeur du problème là parce que
dans leur partie annoncée de villiers
mais y'a comme je disais donc le dénommé
marciani que vous connaissez non parlant
l'ère du parcours est dans les années le
dénommé tard et lui qui est adjoint qui
était adjoint au maire de marignane
simonpieri donc dans sérieux quand on
vous connaît moi je vous connais bon
comment vous un titre comme vous pouvez
être associé à ces gens-là sérieux là
mais moi je suis associé à personne moi
j'ai toujours été convaincu je le
démontre et syndicats doit prendre
encore une fois que le monopole de la
république n'appartenait à personne et
j'ai pu le constater croyant je
rencontre raisons politiques par est il
de gauche ils sont de gauche comme moi
je veux dire je suis papa c'est le cas
de le dire
bon donc j'ai fait un costa et j'ai
toujours y compris aux syndicats
quelqu'un ma ligne politique sur le fait
de transcender les clivages gauche
droite et moi je crois que ce train là
ce sera le train qui réconciliera les
français avec la politique douteux alors
au départ je dis pas que tout est
parfait
marchiani par exemple marc marquez le
préfet marc aymes marque égale j'étais
d'accord avec lui et en désaccord avec
ma famille d'origine à l'époque sur la
faire un thème ntm
voilà je vais le faire expliquait
jean-louis parce qu'ils sont beaucoup le
chabab gt gt d'enquêté
y aurait t 1 voilà bon bien que même
quand elles exigent le respect c'est
quand ils avaient laissé leurs diatribes
contre les flics je veux dire un concert
et seyne-sur-mer
on voit violet of là on va brûler les
commissaires et c'est dire qu'il ya des
limites à tout pour moi la liberté
républicaine
excusez moi après la liberté
républicaine pour moi ce ne consiste pas
à faire tout et n'importe quoi ça
consiste à être libre dans le respect de
la liberté d'autrui
c'est ça le véritable intervient vingt
cadres et quoi il ya une différence
entre l'a10 et et la liberté
d'expression en outre un ce qui nuit à
la dignité autrui pour moi c'est ça le
week-end alors quand on est en concert
avec va si vous avez vu un concert de
ntm aux normes nique la police
joeystarr et kool shen c'est un moment
où ils disent niktamère ntm nick kool
shen nick joey starr nique nique le
premier rang nique la police il ne sait
pas garder c'était juste se répète alors
évidemment là pour le coup on n'a pas
gardé effectivement si on garde que
nique la police
et si on n'est pas dans le concert si on
sait pas ce qui se passe ici on connaît
pas le cc dont je me rappelerai vers 10h
une filiation
aussi avant de se citer un texte confus
jamais oublier le contexte est bien là
il a remis les choses dans le contexte
juste pour finir deux secondes ce qu on
fait juste
mtm e tm provoque pas de violence ntem
parle de violence il parle du parle
d'une situation
elio l'hôtel ou test de leurs que porto
fait d'accord et où l'hôtesse de l'air
elle a mis une gifle d'abord à joey
starr ça on l'a jamais dit il ya eu il
ya eu une embrouille
il ya eu tout un truc qui se trouve que
l'hôtesse de l'air à commencer par gifle
et joey starr je dis pas que c'est bien
on va la retrouver vivante heures ça
s'est très mal passé qu'il est un peu
chaud il y prend une gifle il en remet
une
jamais vraiment entendu que le
que la gifle à chaque fois le plus on a
ce don le plus on a des informations le
mieux c'est quand même je pense que ntm
ne fabrique pas de la violence alors à
eux qui sont une question jean louis
tout par rapport justement à ce que dit
à l'ats pourquoi étant ce que vous êtes
et avec les idées vous savez pourquoi ne
pas aller vers le mouvement des citoyens
de jean pierre chevènement bonne chose
parce que moi je vous verrai plus
sérieusement je vous verrai plus au
mouvement les citoyens avec chevènement
parce que c'est une gauche effectivement
qui est républicaine qui est un peu
nationaliste folie enfin bon et c'est
toute la gauche oui enfin celle là elle
est un peu plus que les autres
pourquoi pas chevènement ça il faut lui
demander à lui allez vous a pas voulu
non c'est pas ça c'est que le mdc ou ce
qu'il en reste aujourd'hui le mouvement
né citoyen était un mouvement dans
lequel je me reconnaissais faut dire le
mieux
1 le problème c'est que quand même
pierre chevènement est revenue
de l'au-delà entre guillemets de notre
rire comme il l'a dit si bien
bon j'aurais souhaité mois qu'il aille
jusqu'au bout de ses convictions
d'ailleurs je lui ai dit d'ailleurs
qu'il aille jusqu'au bout de cette
commission et qu'il rejoigne charles
pasqua sur une base souverainiste il ne
l'a pas fait pourquoi comme parce qu'ils
en avaient proposé parce qu'ils voient
c'est bien fait et tout simplement parce
qu'ils jouent une carte c'est d'être
premier ministre si j'espère les
premiers accords et comme il m'a dit
j'ai 30 ans de politique maintenant j'en
ai marre quoi un bon il fait son choix
fabrice on a mais moi j'étais ravi de
voir monsieur c'est une émission riche
tu manges santé seront chargées
il ya une dame qui a ouai mais avant
qu'elle arrive on va faire on va baisser
la lumière et linda vous faire un croque
monsieur
[Applaudissements]
linda est vite avoue jean-louis
arrageois le qu'est ce que vous regardez
en premier chez une femme ne font parle
pas politique du tout je peux le voir
les premiers se sont encore bien
évidemment quand je vous vois à savon
fait la joie du chou l'accord bon quelle
est la pire insulte qu'une femme puisse
vous faire mais quand je suis à ses
côtés dans le lit de me dire vraiment
écoute je peux pas alors c'est terrible
ça c'est ya rien de plus faux sera pour
tous renoncé à se méfier et bien je
crois que la royale c'est le le le maho
papistes balladuriens solaire ce qui est
l est et l italie au national
républicain guérissent les propos
l'association raisonnable est parfait la
semaine dernière on avait un maoki berry
il ya maintenant il ya des croisements
des hybridations en politique sont allés
jusqu'à cent fleurs s'épanouissent et où
la politique est ce que vous êtes plutôt
porte jarretelles ou au culotte petit
bateau le doute sur sa part ça va bien
merci jean louis pujol dents
j'accueille maintenant lampes les ailes
bonsoir on m'avait dit que j'étais jolie
mais on n'avait pas raconter d'histoires
c'est magnifique
il a dû pôle luchini lui sur les clauses
et sa cote est justement de l'envoi le
couche
pardonnez moi j'étais persuadé dans mon
clichés des luttes en données mensuelles
petite je croyais que vous étiez vous
savez une grande vedette du sport en
plus et d'un sport hyper noble donc là
ça devient très très près à leur rocade
on comprend là vous avez du bol parce
que vous avez une technique maîtrisée
parce que c'est hyper dur il parking un
mysticisme nous quand on fait le plein
mais financo des films en costumes on
nous apprend qu'à relief pour ça des
gens qui nous apprend on est capable on
prend les épaisseurs on est incapable
mais quand on sait qu'on a en face de
nous une femme qui maîtrise ça qui est
éblouissante de beauté on y va
alors mes amis mesdames messieurs chers
amis c'est pas vraiment la paix il a
juste 2 millions de gens qui aimeraient
savoir qu'il en avait parlé donc le 3,9
en 1999 laura flessel est devenue
championne du monde des scream
je suis fasciné par vous la bande alors
vous êtes en plus favorite pas pour les
jeux olympiques de sydney tout à fait en
fait pour le moment c'est moi qui
détiens les les titres en fait de
chanter double championne olympique donc
sonné titre à défendre pendant dix mois
on verra ce que ça va donner
ouais alors vous êtes vous aimez bien
faire de la télé vous avez bien passat
et vous avez dit je suis d'une nature
curieuse et à force d'être tout le temps
passif devant la télévision et à
regarder a critiqué des émissions j'ai
voulu voir le travail en amont
oui tout à fait donc voilà c'est un
plateau d'ardisson les cameramans
regarder les cadreurs j'aurais dit
bonjour en passant donc cédric arrêtez
ça tout seul alors vous êtes né à pointe
à pitre 1 pointe à pitre en guadeloupe
non mais toi tu savais vraiment j'avais
jeté charriots a voulu que samedi en
martinique
vous avez commencé la danse à 6 ans à
l'âge de 6 ans et un jour vous voyez
jean françois lamour à la télévision en
fait j'étais fasciné par les films de
cape et d'épée plus exactement elle a
commencé avec ivanhoe non plus le fanfan
la tulipe les trois mousquetaires le
bossu donc donc de fil en aiguille un
jour j'ai vu une rétrospective de match
de sabre c'était pour moi des scream
moderne et le lendemain je me trouvais
dans un club et c'est parti comme ça ça
à faire 23 ans comme toi quand tu as vu
un film de cul le lendemain c'était dans
un club
maintenant vous avez été plusieurs fois
championne de guadeloupe on vous appelle
la guêpe wee man de parme jeudi à m
ma petite taille lorsque j'ai commencé
les scream c'est vrai que j'étais fine
filiforme
mais j'avais vu déborder d'énergie c'est
qu'il faut savoir c'est que à l'origine
j'étais un petit garçon manqué donc je
mangeais coule encore fait à ma première
compétition je ne connaissais que de
coups et on m'a dit tant qu'il n'ya pas
al tu continues tu vas chercher la
touche et en fait c'était assez
folklorique parce que la fille qu'elle
était plaquée sur le mur et moi je
continue à appliquer vous êtes d'où vous
êtes venus alors à vous d en france en
créant fin métropole pardon en quelle
année
en 90 91 on sait qu'il faut savoir c'est
que j'étais déjà détecté mais j'avais
pas aussi je me sentais pas suffisamment
prêtes pour quitter ma famille quitter
le département le soleil et venir ici
donc j'ai dit que en fait je viendrai
après le bac donc à 18 ans avec le bac
il fallait qu'on une décision parties à
rester mais quand on est arrivé ici vous
dites j'ai été laissé en marge c'est une
bonne question niveau mais c'était ma
couleur je faisais tâche vous avez
souffert on arrivée en france de ben ali
ce crime c'est vrai que c'est une
certaine éthique ça une certaine
notoriété c'est moi qui avais pas
beaucoup de noirs dans ce dossier dans
ce sport donc c'est vrai que quand je
suis arrivé sur touche arrivé dans une
équipe où il y avait déjà des piliers
qui ne voulait pas bouger et moi
j'arrivais je vais j'avais envie de
prouver de me prouver que je n'avais pas
quitter mon département pour rien et si
vous êtes très guadeloupe avoue marc
vous dessinez la guadeloupe sur vos
chaussures et tout ça vous êtes très
sains
quand même vous êtes plus la guadeloupe
indépendante ou non si on peut si ça se
prépare
pourquoi pas mais pour le moment on
n'est pas prêt on n'a pas suffisamment
les reins solides pour faire ça alors
maintenant j'ai une mauvaise nouvelle
pour nous tous ici vous êtes marié face
et le coup dur ça arrive comme ça
brutalement
non il ya un truc terrible c'est que
vous dites quand je me regarde dans un
miroir c'est lui que je vois en parlant
denis oui il est derrière ce moment
enfin moi je voyais et là c'est à dire
que bon effectivement si le fait d'être
marié
enfin la convaincante quand laura se
voit dans un miroir c'est denis que je
retrouve pas tout le temps se regardant
un poster à la pas content j'ai eu la
chance de trouver un homme compréhensif
pense que c'est vrai que le statut
d'athlète de haut niveau est quand même
lourd à gérer puisque quasiment partie
lui les journalistes donc lui aussi de
par son métier n'est jamais là à mai
non non on arrive à se retrouver c'est
vrai que en fait on arrive d'horizons
différents puisqu'il est d'origine
yougoslave et
et en fait c'est vrai que bon on a quand
même pas mal de temps comment on se
complète avec lui tout à fait bien alors
de toute façon il ya plus grave encore
que de nice et après sydney ma plus
belle médaille ce sera mon bébé je leur
ai assez attendu oui ça sera notre dame
est salle r tu es toujours conquérir la
terre entière sait refroidissant une
fille qui aime son jules à ce point là
et qu'il veut un bébé de lui et tout de
suite apprécié et très bien au contraire
avant tout ça refroidit une expérience
nécessaire ça me refroidit pas vous
fabrice ce qu'il faut c'est que vous
avez dit une chose magnifique c'est que
c'est fusionnel avec denis j'avais dit
vous êtes là qu il ait vous-même quoi
oui c'est beau c'est prodigieux et ça
vous angoisse par moment parce que c'est
une perte de la frontière des angoisses
pas non pas du tout mais quand vous êtes
lui par moments je pense et lui vous
c'est lui qui gagnent des médailles d'or
trois tweets à l'attention des enfants
ont lancé une émission énorme problème
premier problème vous avez décidé de
quitter le racing club de france qui
vous avait accueilli lorsque vous êtes
arrivé de guadeloupe
parce qu'ils veulent plus payer de prime
aux athlètes de haut niveau
alors ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'il
ya une nouvelle politique et la
politique justement renier le sport de
haut niveau
donc ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que les
scream c'est un sport amateur et que à
cause de ça enfin grâce à ça ça nous
permet d'avoir un certain équilibre
on est obligé de travailler donc on
garde un pied dans la vie active mais ce
qu'il faut savoir aussi c'est que on ne
peut pas travailler à 100% donc un
manque à gagner que le club nous donnait
et le problème qui s'est passé c'est que
un des jeux à dix mois des jeux ils ont
ils ont carrément décidé de retirer sans
les gars moi je pense que c'est un
problème politique
et comme nous le sportif n'avoue pas le
temps du fait qu'elle lui donne de
l'argent ne me dit plus il m'est
difficile profitez-en
pendant tout le monde est au courant
donc en fait on a on a quand même opté
pour rester au club
pendant toute la saison à bonal et nous
allons vous inscrire à chantilly où ben
c'était à la date butoir de
pour changer en fait c'était le 15
novembre la raison pour laquelle on
n'était pas plus aucun petit lézard mais
ça peut s'arranger
ben là on a trouvé un club accueillant
qui croient au sport de haut niveau et
qui justement nous aider donc voilà on a
chanté c'est incroyable alors on va
c'est le club de quoi de chantilly de
chantilly ce que je viens de dire bien
donc je dis ça pour les gens qui me
disent quel club en régie alors on va
regarder quelques quelques mais
catherine il faut on va regarder
quelques photos de vous formidable vous
allez m'expliquer ce que si ces photos
d'aller regarder comme vous êtes belle
alors c'est après les joueurs en 96 à
nancy les vêtements de jean paul
gaultier bon compte après la suivante
s'il vous plaît monsieur kalfon voilà
toujours encore c'était
la collection avec l'écho les massaï
donc c'est vrai que je m'apprêtais à ces
photos et c'est vrai que c'était
magnifique
c'est très joli encore une ohlala ah oui
cela est très bien c'est grave de l'est
de la voilà avec le blé ski moderne bien
alors maintenant je veux faire comme
c'est la première fois qu'on se voie je
vous faire une interview première fois
on ne bouge pas elle a bougé les bouger
là on recommence aura lieu attention je
vais vous faire une interview première
fois
[Musique]
elle peut pas s'empêcher de vous est
craquante a franchement inscrit à vous
êtes t'offre à quand bien premier
souvenir
bonjour j'ai rencontré jean françois
lamour guadeloupe
il est venu en plus en guadeloupe après
la télé vous a vu à la télé il est venu
vraiment aussi j'ai rencontré l'amour
c'est le jour il m'a signé le premier
autographe
ouais ça c'est grand souvenir c'est vrai
a décidé de votre premier péché dit la
vérité ici on dit la vérité c'est pas
comme d'habitude de la télé ici on dit
la vérité
j'avais plus que les bonbons de mon
frère et j'avais juré que c'était pas
moi non je m'attendais à un prix
beaucoup plus hard à ses premiers essais
le premier bon deuxième à la première
idole bon jean françois lamour ont fait
dire oui c'était pas d'un mot non
c'était carl lewis à carl lewis et
premier amour mauvais souvenirs à vent
mauvais souvenir non c'est un escrimeur
* rumeurs et je reste encore dans les
films normalement tu devrais dire il
tirait mal je sais pas ce que tu fous
merde moi bon premier flirt et irait mal
non c'est le même ouais premier rock
premier amour premiers flirts premier
homme c'est le même escrimeurs zéro
pointé c'est ça oui ça plaît à
moi c'est de ma faute votre première
cuite
je l'attends toujours jean heureusement
peur du lendemain dont je ramène plutôt
que je vais à bord votre 1er juin pas
encore vous avez tout à découvrir
attendait mais c'est le faut regarder
quel âge tu t'en de 8 ans oui premier
dopage et j'envisage pas ah bon vous
droguez pas vous non pour le moment je
savais comment les sections bac au mans
pour l'ex-champion du monde sans vous
dopez mons entraînant et en croyant
en étant entouré par une bonne
par de bonnes personnes ça c'est beau
surtout c'est sûr que je suis passionné
donc oui ça s'applaudit sa championne
ça fait beaucoup et je vais vous dire un
truc je ne le connais pas je n'aime pas
beaucoup ce demi j'ai passé une partie
pratique ce seuil ou parce que c'est pas
une nationalité c'est une profession
méfier évolué bien
philips nous quitter alors on ne demande
pas où vous allez parce que ça c'est
peut-être un peu un discret non vous
allez ou dans la nature dans la maison à
messieurs bien philippe sollers
voilà j'en connais un qui respecte l
escrime rapidement bourges accueille
maintenant hélène rôle et jackie
bonsoir bonsoir comment ça va ça va et
toi bats toi
ouais super super ouais ouais hélène ça
va très bien merci
une faille penser vue oui alors j'ai un
petit truc justement pour tous les deux
pour les deux un bon seuil où certains
c'était c'était lui inquiété ou c'était
lio et de soins l'ios et vous oui oui on
fait semblant de ce vous voyez à la télé
tu perds lors que je te vois alors ouais
tu permets que je te vois alors n roll
bonsoir dont ils sont déroulé ce lundi
relais sous la caresse à la fin il ya un
accent grave sur le dakar c'est tout on
voulait d'avoir des intrus n'a pas de
bol là on dit boles leur retour à la
télé donc vous participez au feuilleton
les vacances de l'amour qui est tourné
fin novembre jusqu'à fin décembre saint
martin ouais je vais y participer sont
elles pas encore fait lui à l'ouragan
les mille ha ouais ouais j'avais
toujours d'accord et diffusion février
2000 je le dis pour les amis d'hélène
qui sont nombreux
un album en cours d'écriture oui sortie
printemps 2000
alors est ce que c'est que cette
nouvelle énergie vous vient de votre
nouveau fiancé parce que j'ai un nouveau
fiancé 20 cents à 20 cents
mais j'ai commencé à ces jeunes parce
que vous étiez enfant vous étiez prêté
par votre maman avec votre soeur sophie
comme demoiselle d'honneur à des
mariages sont séparés c'est pas beau ça
à prêter non enfin oui on allait on
allait à ouais c'est à dire le contraire
de tout ce que je vais dire ça me
dérange pas j'ai l'habitude comment vous
prêter pour être demoiselle d'honneur
dans des mariages et sa famille c'était
la famille quand même c'était pas des
gens tu vois oui vous initier les
clauses et à la perfection
vous venez ça j'étais fan de tout
françois fans oui on a tous été rejetés
les chars d'amitié bien aussi c'est une
écharde oui vous faites plus ça c'est
fini
pas de pot et alors vous avez eu un coup
de bol absolument incroyable l'asie
correspondant
j'ai eu un coup de bol est absolument
incroyable en soixante dix huit votre
mémé qui paie plus la main mais paulette
paulette votre mémé l île journal
paulette et elle voit qu'on cherche pour
un film que c'est le mouton noir de
moscardo avec dutronc une fille avec les
yeux bleus oui voilà
et comme vous aimez beaucoup elle vous a
quand même conseillé d'y aller vous
allez gagner 3000 candidate et vous avez
gagné le concours bien que n'ayant pas
les yeux le premier coup de chance ouais
gros coup de chance deuxième coup de
chance et payer le journal 5000
candidats décroche le deuxième coup de
chance votre maman organise au mans un
concert pour dorothée - entre autres à
l'organiser depuis un an des concerts
voilà parce que j'étais avant c'est vrai
même si call dorothée et moi même avant
je suis si certains enfants hélène voilà
c'était un état giro c'est la plongée
elle m'a serré dans le catering mais
vous rencontré jean-luc allouche azoulay
qui deviendra votre mentor optionné de 7
laissez vous avez fait dans la salle
vide tous les deux et je me souviens
vous souvenez ouais c'est pas si vieux
je vais jouer quoi je vais pas jouer
chanter
vous avez chanté quoi des chansons
dorothée change quoi pour essayer de
chansons de dorothée jean coalisés
quelques-unes bah oui mes nièces et mes
petits cousins une petite cousine
alors voilà deux coups de chance
absolument incroyable coup sur coup
le journal de paulette l'audition avec
jean luc azoulay et vous voilà lancé non
mais c'est vrai c'est incroyable moi je
me suis toujours très intéressé de
savoir comment les gens en quelle
qualité le déclic le la boîte à
angoulême pour fabrice luchini non mais
c'est vrai c'est d'ailleurs un moment
important dans l'émission c'est la
difficulté qu'on a mis à mettre en
branle
oui et c'était ce qui était à mon avis
le plus beau c'est cette difficulté et
ça c'est une chose à laquelle je reviens
de mec qu'a pas compris que cette
rencontre cette rencontre d'une maserati
oui vous savez au début de l'émission
chère madame monsieur thierry ardisson
c'est nous on est là depuis quand même
pas mal de est dans une espèce de lâcher
prise s'avère que les faits les ja de
l'abandon des postures dégrade pas vous
avez remarqué ce côté est arrivée
seconde est arrivée dans la rétraction
parce que ça il faut savoir que j'arrive
toujours dans une inquiétude est que
notre ami laurent avait pointé juste
titre ajusté toujours au début je ne
ramène pas les choses à moi je fais tout
nombre dans la difficulté un peu de
rédactions ce qui est bien normal comme
vous au début et puis après il ya
dilatation il ya d'amour vous allez
comprendre
l'attraction dilatation et c'est une
perspective mais là maintenant on est
dans une espèce de plus rien avant
d'ailleurs moi vraiment je n'ai jamais
rare mais s'est plaint le spectacle
avait vu ce que vous arrivez dans un
climat de profonde presque de dérivés on
ne sait plus trop comment s'appellent
les hiérarchies sont calmes et plus
personne ne sait combien l'eau de gan on
sait plus qui est qui
on sait qu'il ya des sportifs de très
haut niveau on les devine on sent qu'ils
ont dit
et le physique et le génie de grands et
le demi et on sait qu'ils sont mariés
avec la yougoslave et faut pas
l'emmerder promisec alain chabat est là
et que est que nous sommes tous là qu'il
ya eu rencontre entre mal et il ya eu un
truc vous arrivez dans ce climat broulis
l' émission normal je vous dis non je
vous dis émission je vous dis un mot
habituellement épouvantable lâcher prise
bon alors continuons en continu tous les
deux ben oui oui on est seul au monde
encore 87 premiers 45 tours 89 premier
album 91 premier baiser enfin la série
et 92 92
fous de ça moi aussi mais maîtrise j'en
ai parlé très longtemps dans une
émission domaines de la société comme un
phénomène de société la ln magna ça
existe et 600 épisodes 6 millions de
fans
wen et auxerre 10 - il n'y a pas
d'orgueil micola
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
art sont en version russe évidemment il
n'y avait pas la bande internationale
donc ils baisser le son français pour
mettre le sang russe par devant c'était
juste après la chute du communisme n'est
pas les moyens extraordinaires la même
fille qui fait toutes les voix de fille
et le même garçon pourquoi il faut dire
quand même chose quand je parlais
d'hélène magna et c'est dans le monde
entier
cette série était vendu dans le monde
entier vous avez touché beaucoup là
dessus
bah ouais normal change pas non mais ses
conséquences et non mais c'est bien je
ne sais pas moi j'ai pas de comparaison
non non bon vous avez fait un disque qui
s'appelle je m'appelle hélène pourquoi
vous l'avez pages en effet si c'est bien
sûr vous avez fait bercy faisait
faillite mais pourra vous l'avez demandé
que hélène je m'appelle hélène soit
retiré de la vente je comprends pas ça
moi j'ai demandé ça non je sais pas
quand j'ai cherché le disque on m'a dit
a demandé que ce soit retirée ah non je
suis désolé non vous n'êtes pas demandé
que ledit soit retirée non pas qu on
peut l'écouter c'est bien pourquoi on
peut continuer quoi quoi
je m'habille ggc plus
je sais pas vous n'avez pas demandé que
soient retirés de la vente
non qu'elle dise exactement regardez
beaucoup parce que je sais tout
simplement ya pas de second degré c'est
simplement un plaisir c'est toute une
histoire parce que quand tu as une image
et une fille et c'est quand même pour
tous les gens qui ont eu la chance
d'avoir des enfants de 8 à 14 ans peu
importe
à cette époque là c'était quand même
pour le père une manière de montrer à sa
fille qu'on n'était pas trop cons et
qu'on pouvait vraiment se faire le miel
et les abeilles avant et hélène et les
garçons
moi je me tapais les deux et mine de
rien vous êtes redevable à plein de père
qui pouvait avoir l'air de ringard et
avec toutes les problématiques qu'on
avec ses enfants de se rapprocher
vachement bien d'écouter des feuilletons
de cette qualité là alors non mes
blagues à paris un sociologue qui
s'appelle dominique persky au service
qu'il a fait c'est incroyable il a
décortiqué des milliers de là c'est une
femme apte une femme
les cantiques et des milliers de lettres
et finalement il a trouvé que c'était
très positif les veines le feuilleton
hélène et les garçons c'est énorme
très positif il a dit que c'est un
programme de vie qu'ils aient réfléchir
et téléspectateurs les amis les parents
que ça engendrait des discussions sur
les enjeux du couple
les rapports hommes/femmes limites de la
liberté sexuelle oui en velin lary d'or
de de votre mec par exemple c'est parce
que lui il était hallucinant ce que
j'adorerais dans le temps ces trois
scellés des lieux de la musique c'est à
dire que lisa est précédée ce café canal
plus après on les voyait toujours
prendre un tout petit peu la guitare et
comme ils savaient pas hyper bien jouer
les mêmes qu'on les entende à faire
wellens vois pas pourquoi tout comme sa
musique ce soir
un peu comme canal+ ouvert les mecs très
angoissée défaut le il s'était
simplement débile guitare par la
tristesse d'amour écrite est amis on
attendait sébastien les navettes
oui quand même quand ils se réunissaient
s'appelait oui non mais oui
hélène à vous et vous avez passé votre
mari n'était pas musicien
oui non mais je ne les critique pas je
dis qu'il y avait but ou défendre le dit
que après le miel et les abeilles qui
nous offrait une perspective large
d'haïti soit beaucoup plus là on était
dans des problèmes plus tendue avec
votre feuilleton parce que c'était un
problème du de l'incompréhension ce que
vous finalement vous étiez carré votre
rôle était une femme carrés qui mettait
en scène
l'impuissance quand même de ce garçon
qui était normal mais quand il y avait
le drogué vous vous rappelez quand il y
avait le drogué le gars qui avait fait
d'ailleurs là votre mari le gave d'agde
était vachement il incarnait la raison
qui l'a carmela moral des mains tu vas
rester comme ça comme une loque
alors l'autre faisais mais laisse moi
mais laisse moi et c'était exactement
très étonnant parce que c'était des gens
qui avait 75 ans un coup pareil dit
qu'elle allait passer mais on aurait dit
qu'ils avaient déjà des projets de gens
d'une cinquantaine d'années alors dès
qu'il avait un marginal
c'était comment il s'appelait est-ce que
c'était cricri que c'était bien ensemble
oui bon c'est donc très creeks et myla
rose
vous maîtrisez mire la drogue mais ils
ont ils l'ont qu'ils ont croqué d'une
manière eux il ya drop délirante quoi la
drogue
et puis live votre mec comment il
s'appelait nicolas nicolas
ils ont de plus en plus loin il avait
les cheveux de plus en plus longs et
c'est ce que j'aimais beaucoup
évidemment c'est banal c'était ce salon
de thé enfin cette espèce de
[Applaudissements]
soit mais nous malacca fait ouais comme
à dix corps et qui était le lieu unique
du marivaudage tient après le miel et
les abeilles
vous croyez que c'était facile de passer
à votre univers pas si évident et
pourquoi y en avait une qui était
toujours flipper en amour c'était
laquelle qu'ils aient toujours mais il n
comment tu fais toi ton couple images
combien c'est quoi ce n'est pas la lie
laly laly vous pouvez mourir un la lys
était effrayant parce que non mais là
lyon mais c'est pas pour balancer sur
une actrice à laly qui peut devenir fou
rire avec la nuit c'était la boudeuse
éternel c'était celle avec qui avait
jamais sexe et vous vous apparaissiez
éclaboussant d' équilibre avec votre
nico je vous haïssez 1 en général a
réussi son couple elle l'a dit madame
soleil a dit vous finirez philosophes ou
dans les ordres s'est planté oui
germaine ouais c'était sûr mais c'était
je n'irai ni philosophique dans les
ordres
j'en sais rien mahdia partir de 40 ans
ma vie allait changer ah bon bon on va
passer avoue alors justement la question
c
jacky c'est à dire parce qu on voit puis
chez dorothée depuis la fin du club
dorothée
oui je préparais mon court métrage ouais
il est formidable court métrage
oui j'en ai évidemment gelé ramon pipin
benghazi par amélie extraordinaire votre
court-métrage c'est un court métrage
d'une vraie catharsis était le symbole
métrage où vous vous mettez en scène
comme un type qui a fait hélène et les
garçons qui a plus de boulot il y anime
à un supermarché et c'est d'une vérité
je trouve ça formidable on peut serge
est ce qu'on peut voir un extrait du
court métrage de jacky
tiens salut à tous et jacques et du club
dorothée
je suis grave content d'être avec vous
cet après midi parce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est mon anniversaire que j'ai 32 ans
je pense qu'on va passer un super moment
ensemble
est-ce que vous êtes prêts allez on y va
tous t'appelles comment mon prénom c'est
comme ça moi je riais pas des photos un
peu plus récentes
c'est joli comme prénom ces bretons
n'ont ukrainien moi je regardais
beaucoup votre émission quand j'étais
plus jeune tu es toujours jeune tatiana
retrouve mois à la zone les livraisons
poissonnerie juste après la dédicace je
te fera goûter mon sac bousquet
et toi comment tu t'appelles c'est pas
pour moi c'est pour moi un petit fils et
je l'adoré
ben oui même plus les morts il ya cinq
ans la tête brûlée par un but
la série à qui jacques higelin küblis et
tu récoltes aura ce que tu as ce n'est
un court métrage s'est passé en première
partie du film le créateur d'albert
dupontel et qui est réalisé par ramon
pipin oui fondateur du bonheur des dames
bien je dis non oui c'est vachement bien
l'ambiance est bien c'est bien filmé
brasserie merci au revoir monsieur vous
étiez alors on s'y reconnaît les faits
voilà c'est bien
et alors maintenant vous êtes sur la
télévision française juive
voilà alors ça c'est un truc qu'on va
trouver une télévision française
vivement ma toujours expliqué quand
j'étais petit les juifs c'est comme nous
il faut pas faire de différence il faut
penser parce que les catholiques
musulmans juifs
on est tous pareils et tout est le fait
qu'une télévision française juive c'est
quand même du communautarisme non chez
moi c'est télévision juive qui émet en
france quoi en fait
voilà c'est tout simplement ça se passe
avoue chose cette chose on va y revenir
je passe souvent d'accord avec ardisson
mais la teda partiel femmes spécial
jouets spéciale au bleu marine
mais on aura la télé des philatélistes
et là non c'est pas pareil philatélistes
moi je trouve que on a toujours expliqué
qu'il fallait pas faire de différence
entre les gens je pense j'ai été élevé
comme ça mais j'étais après la guerre
faut dire donc il fallait calmer le jeu
un bon mais maintenant je trouve ça un
retour au communautarisme qui t'a pas
inquiétant parce que dit on a mis les 8
watts et sean qui est assez ouverte non
mais c'est une chasse ouverte chaplin
démission samedi à tottenham qui est mal
choisi une télévision française juifs
cohabitaient c'est pas mal de choses
vous faites un show qui s'appelle le
rabbi jackie chan oui bah écoute et on
va voir vraiment un extrait donc de la
cmj la télévision française bible on
s'habille jackie chan et autres c'est ma
première émission sur tv7 et que moi par
des écoutes alors là c'est alors que
tout va se casser la gueule ça va
terrifier télévision gilles du mois a
fait les circoncis oui ça y est je suis
preneur mais tu es juif il paraît assez
donné une ancienne une ancienne vie
enfin aujourd'hui considèrent comme
athée ouais je crois pas la grand chose
vous avez fait votre bar mitsva ben j'ai
fait des trucs comme ça et j'ai eu du
mal je viens 13 ans vous étiez en retard
ou en avance ne mettez pas tous en
retard comme le pack
je sais que c'est mon frère qui parle à
ma place et chanter la place ça on peut
la voir comment cette télé c'est la
lyonnaise câble canal 30
cal altran d'avoir surtout ps bientôt
mais bientôt sur ppr
ouais mais c'est sympa remue jeunes bien
où ils se donnent trois là alors quand
on vous voit tous les deux on a toujours
envie de vous demande un peu ce que sont
devenus les autres corbier qu'est-ce qui
est devenu il est juge et flic
il est plus tard me cormier vit en
normandie
ouais il fait un peu de théâtre au havre
il fait du cabaret à paris temps en
temps il va bien oui ça brûle en forme
vous n'êtes pas au courant vous avez
laissé tomber vos mains moi c'était plus
les potes déjà qui en fait un oui et
ariane pas ce qu'est devenu l'ariana
toujours chez abb gachon avant oui elle
a épousé un muscle et ariane la paix
tous élevés qu'à muscles la vie elle est
taxée camuset voilà un et bernard minet
alors aucune nouvelle lutte au maire
d'alors versa mais ça c'est sûr vous
connaissez bien terminé quand même un
bon gardien bah oui à temps et la
guadeloupe c'est la france
bernard si tu nous entends chez nous
ainsi comme gérard palaprat nous l'a
appris au nom tu connais toi qui voulais
tout le répertoire du matin envahie et
une petite tu vois canada bonne et pas
te gêne pas de le gagner soirée à
l'intérieur de deux des vacances de
l'amour voilà bien et dorothée de
retenir son pose un regard du terrible
narnia truc terrible sur dirt et je sais
que j'ai déjà un franc provient menace
au dos sa maman est décédée le jour du
dernier tournage oui elle était enterré
le jour de la dernière dit c'était une
horreur ouais du club dorothée venir du
monde
voilà
c
enfin le livre de philippe sollers qui
s'appelle l'oeil de proust éxisté stocks
je leur fais sécher stock l'oeil de
proust autres l'idée philippe sollers
beaucoup plus petit beaucoup moins cher
un amour américain dit francine nouvelle
voilà pierre desproges la cassette
desproges et vivant voilà canal + vidéo
qu'à la puce vidéo six bris call girl de
alain chabat pierre desproges le petit
rapporteur c'est un livre de ses
sketches voilà laurent baffie sur europe
2 tous les soirs c'est quoi ce bordel
21h 23h intime vers 23 heures c'est quoi
ce bordel vous on vous retrouve le
racing mais on va croiser les doigts à
croiser les doigts
voilà rabie chaki show tous les jours
canal 30 sur tfj la lyonnaise la
lyonnaise vous on vous retrouve au monde
printemps dont la diffusion s'est noyé
peu près je sais je sais pas vous savez
pas encore non pas vous partez tourné en
toile et fabrice luchini donc à partir
du 4 décembre au théâtre de la madeleine
pour des textes de rictus hugo
baudelaire nietzsche céline on invitait
tous ensemble mais on y va tous essayer
qui invite est énorme et bien sûr
il y en a une sur adrien inquiets sur
invité aussi il ya un projet possible
d'y accéder à des acquisitions
le res j'ai déjà dit aux anges voilà
c'était rendez-vous alors là le rendez
vous d'un super loin c'est le 11
décembre merci france 2 en vain
[Musique]